GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME TO
THE APRIL SEVENTH HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE. AND THIS IS OUR
FIRST BILL HEARING OF THE
TWENTY ONE TWENTY TWO SESSION.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME OUR
NEW AND RETURNING MEMBERS TO
THE COMMITTEE- WE HAVE ASSEMBLY
MIGHT CHARITABLY WOMAN DAVIES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRIS WARD. AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PHILIP WHO THE
NEW TO THE COMMITTEE- AND
MYSELF THE WELCOME LOOK FOR TO
WORKING TOGETHER THIS YEAR. AT
TO START I'D LIKE TO THANK ALL
OF OUR STAFF THAT HAVE MADE
POSSIBLE OUR ABILITY TO
MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES FOR SAFE
PARTICIPATION IN HEARINGS. TO
THAT END A LITTLE SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING TODAY REGARDING
PUBLIC PARTICIPATION. TO HELP
PRESERVE THE SAFETY OF EVERYONE
HERE TODAY AND TO ENSURE THE
PUBLIC'S ASK ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. DO THE CURRENT
STATE HOME ORDER WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCE
SEEING A FACE COVERING
REQUIREMENTS FOR EVERYONE HERE.
IN THE HEARING ROOM AND
THROUGHOUT THE CAPITOL
BUILDING. WE ARE ONLY ABLE TO
HAVE A LIMITED NUMBER OF PEOPLE
WATCH AND PARTICIPATE IN THE
HEARING IN PERSON. WE HAVE A
FEW DIFFERENT OPTIONS FOR
WITNESS TESTIMONY TODAY. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE ROOM AND ROOM
FOR TWO OR TWO WE'RE HAVING TO
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING IN THE SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND PRESENTING
MEMBERS A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF
STAFF AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF
THE PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN. SIX FEET OF SPACING
IF ANY MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN
THE ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
ON A BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR
HAND AND I'LL ASK YOU TO
APPROACH THE MICROPHONE. I ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TO TOUCH
THE MARK FROM PLEASE. FOR
DIALING WITNESSES WILL BE USING
A MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE.
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALL IN
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING. IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE TWO.
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE ONE.
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE WEBSITE AS WELL AS ON
YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL
YOU'RE TESTIFYING ON IS
BEGINNING THEIR BILL
PRESENTATION. THE OPERATOR ON
THE LINE WILL GIVE YOU
INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BELL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. THIS INCLUDES MUTING
YOUR LIVE STREAM BROADCAST. AND
YOUR SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE
THE SOUND DISTORTION. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE
SIX. THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO
EIGHT NINE AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. IN
ADDITION WITNESSES WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO USE ONE OF
OUR REMOTE. TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED ON THE CAPITOL GROUNDS
TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. I'D ALSO
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS
SIMPLY ISN'T COUNTERED REPEATED
DISRUPTIONS OF ITS PROCEEDINGS
IN RECENT YEARS AND IS
DISRUPTIONS HAVE INCREASED THIS
YEAR. RECENT DISRUPTIONS OF
GOVERNMENT PROCEEDINGS HERE IN
THE ASSEMBLY AND AT THE US
CAPITOL NECESSITATE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS AND RULES
AGAINST DISRUPTION. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. IT DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY YOU WILL
BE REMOVED FROM THE HEARING
ROOM BY THE ASSEMBLY SERGEANTS
ARE YOU WILL BE REMOVED FROM
THE CALL. TODAY ONCE WE HAVE
ESTABLISHED QUORUM WILL BE
VOTING TO ADOPT OR COMMITTEE
RULES. THEN WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
BILLS ON THE AGENDA EIGHTEEN OF
WHICH ARE ON CONSENT. PLEASE
NOTE THAT WE LIMIT TESTIMONY TO
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
TWO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
EACH WITNESS HAS TWO MINUTES TO
TESTIFY ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES MAY ADD ON BY STATING
YOUR NAME AND AFFILIATION. SO
SECRETARY BELIEVE WE HAVE A
QUORUM. CALDERON I DAVIS HERE
ARAMBULA CHOI HERE GIPSON.
STONE FILOPODIA HERE WORK HERE
YOU HAVE A CAR. THANK YOU. SO
THAT WE COULD FOR TO PROVE THE
RULES SECOND. I'M SORRY. IT IT
IT OKAY. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ON THE COMMITTEE ROLES CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES DAVIES
I ARAMBULA REGULAR HIGH CHOI HI
CHOI I GIPSON GIPSON AYE STONE.
STONE I THE LIKUD HI. I LOWERED.
HI THAT IS A TWO ZERO. THANK
YOU AND THEN- NEXT WEEK ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. THANK YOU.
THE FOLLOWING MEASURES ARE ON
CONSENT. AB THIRTEEN TWENTY SIX
BY REGULARLY SB SIX SEVEN FOUR
BENNETT. AB TEN FIFTY ONE
BENNETT AB TWELVE NINETY FOUR
BONTA. EIGHTY FOUR FORTY FIVE
CALDERON SB SIX SEVENTY
CALDERON AB SEVEN EIGHTY EIGHT
CALDERON AB ONE ZERO ZERO FOUR
CALDERON AB EIGHT FORTY ONE
CUNNINGHAM AB FIVE FORTY SIX
MAIENSCHEIN AB THREE SEVENTEEN
PATTERSON AB EIGHT SIXTY FIVE
CORK SILVA. AB FIVE SIXTY EIGHT
OUR RIVAS A. B. ELEVEN FORTY
ARE RIVAS AB THREE SIXTY SIX.
THE L.A. BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN
RUBIO AB ONE ZERO ZERO SIX
RUBIO AND. EIGHTY FOUR THIRTEEN
TEN. SEVEN MOTION I'M CONFIRM
YOUR READY TO ATTACK ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALDERON HI
WALDRON HIGH DAVIES. DAVIES I
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA I CHOI HI
CHOI I GIPSON GIPSON HI STONE
STONE HI- FILOPODIA I BOARD.
LORD HI. SO IT'S A TO. OKAY
THANK YOU. AND I THINK WE'LL
START WITH HER FIRST A
PRESENTER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GIPSON.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT TO
SIMPLY BE A FIVE FOUR NINE.
WHICH WILL SUPPORT BALLING WILL
SUPPORT- VULNERABLE MINORS WHO
ARE AT RISK OF TIMING OUT OF
CRITICAL SUPPORT SERVICES.
COVERT NINETEEN PANDEMIC AS
IMPACTED US ALL EXPRESSLY OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH WHO ARE WHO ARE
NEARLY NEARING THEIR EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY AND UNABLE TO ATTEND
COURT HEARINGS DUE TO COURT
CLOSURES AND HEARING DELAYS. AB
FOUR FIVE NINE. WILL ELIMINATE
BARRIERS TO ENSURE THAT OLDER
FOSTER YOUTH IN NEED OF
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES ARE ABLE
TO ENTER FOSTER YOU. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO GIVE THEM OPPORTUNITY
TO BENEFIT FROM THE SUPPORT OF
EXTENDED SERVICES FOR FALL FOR
YOU THIS BILL. IS A
CONTINUATION OTHER WORK THAT
I'VE DONE OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS TO REDUCE BARRIERS FOR
OUR OLDER FOSTER YOUTH EXTENDED
BOSTICK CARE BENEFITS ARE
CRITICAL AS YOU TRANSITION INTO
ADULTHOOD. THESE YOUTH FACE
GREAT CHALLENGES IN COMPLETING
THEIR EDUCATION FINDING STABLE
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING. THIS
YEAR COBIT NINETEEN RELATED
COURT CASES AND CASES HAVE
DELAYED. HAVE BEEN CLOSURES DUE
TO THIS PANDEMIC CASE WORK
INVESTIGATIONS DELAYED. SHOULD
NOT PREVENT A NARROW GROUP OF
FOSTER YOUTH FROM RECEIVING THE
BENEFITS THAT THEY NEED.
OTHERWISE THEY'LL BE ELIGIBLE
FOR. THE COURT PROCESS LEAVES
OLDER MINORS BARNACLE THE
TIMING OUT OF THE PROCESS IF
THEY TURN EIGHTEEN WHILE
WAITING FOR A COURT HEARING. AB
FOUR FIVE NINE OFFERS AN
EXEMPTION FOR YOU FOR OLDER
MINORS GIVING THEM ACCESS TO
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SUPPORT
SERVICES WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN
REMOVED FROM THEIR HOMES AND
COURTS MAKING THEIR THEIR BEST
INTEREST FINDINGS FOR THEM TO
ENTER INTO EXTENDED FOSTER.
CARE THIS BIL INTENTIONALLY
NARROWS TO IS VERY SPECIFIC.
GROUP OF MINERS WHO ARE AT THE
POINT OF AGING OUT THIS BILL
WILL BE DELAYED WILL. INCREASES
SUNSET UNTIL JANUARY. TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY THREE THIS BILL
IS SUPPORTED BY A NUMBER OF
PEOPLE ON THE LINE WE SHOULD
HAVE A REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE
BAY AREA LEGAL AID.
REPRESENTATIVE AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
THEY WERE BOTH SELF INTRODUCED
IT SHOULD BE ON THE LINE TO
PROVIDE SUPPORTING TESTIMONY
FOR AB FIVE FOUR NINE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
OPERATOR CAN WE OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE FIRST WITNESS. THANK
YOU CAN LUIS YOU MAY BEGIN.
OKAY OKAY GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS MAKE THAT CHANGE I'M A
MANAGING ATTORNEY AT BAY AREA
LEGAL AID AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CO SPONSORS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON. BUT
EIGHTY FIVE FORTY NINE ON
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE. GYRO
TECHNICAL OF A NORM THAT
IMPORTANT TO YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE BARRED FROM ACCESSING
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SERVICES.
YOU TO ADMINISTRATIVE HURDLES
BEYOND THEIR CONTROL. BY WAY OF
BACKGROUND BABY GIRL IS THE
LARGEST PROVIDER OF FREE CIVIL
LEGAL SERVICES TO SAN FRANCISCO
BAY AREA BY STUDENTS LIVING IN
POVERTY. NEFA LEGAL CLIENTS
HAVE BEEN NON MINOR DEPENDENTS
RECEIVING EXTENDED FOSTER CARE
SERVICES. THANKS TO THE PASSAGE
OF THE CALIFORNIA FOSTERING
CONNECTIONS TO SUCCESS ACT IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN YOUNG PEOPLE
WHO TURN EIGHTEEN ACOSTA CARE
ARE ELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE ONGOING
SUPPORT AFTER AGE TWENTY ONE TO
BETTER PREPARE THEM FOR
ADULTHOOD. THE SUPPORT PROVIDED
BY AB TWELVE REPRESENTS A
CRITICAL SAFETY NET TO HELP
TRANSITION AGED YOUTH WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ABUSE ABANDONMENT
AND O'CLOCK AVOID THE POOR LONG
TERM CONSEQUENCES ASSOCIATED
WITH ADVERSE CHILDHOOD
EXPERIENCES. HOWEVER OUR
DEPENDENCY COURT AND COURTS OF
APPEAL HAVE IDENTIFIED SPECIFIC
POPULATIONS OF YOUNG PEOPLE
THAT REMAIN AN ELIGIBLE FOR
THESE CRITICAL SUPPORT. THAT WE
APPRECIATE ASSEMBLY MEMBER GET
SENSE WORK ON OVER THE PAST FEW
YEARS. ST IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL AND A YOUNG PERSON'S LIFE
AND THE CHALLENGES THAT CAN
PARK ACCESS I WOULD LIKE TO
TELL YOU ABOUT MY CLIENT HI. HI
WAS A FOSTER YOUTH WITH A MUCH
YOUNGER CHILD. ALTHOUGH HE WAS
EVENTUALLY REUNIFIED WITH HIS
PARENTS AND SIBLINGS THAT
YOU'VE CONTINUED ON A FREQUENT
BASIS. AND DESPITE. HIGH SCHOOL
COUNSELOR MAKING CPS REPORT
AFTER WITNESSING BRUISES AND
MARKS ON TYLER'S BODY FROM THE
PARENTS TYLER WAS NOT ABLE TO
BE REMOVED FROM THE HOME OF HIS
ABUSIVE PARENTS. LIVE TIED TO
LEAVE THE HOUSE WHEN HE WAS A
TEENAGER TO SEEK REFUGE AT
REFUGE I THANK YOU DR THE
SHELTER AGAIN CONTACTED CPS BUT
AGAIN CPS FAILED TO REMOVE TYPE
FROM THE HOME OF A PARENT. HI
THE TERABYTES TO RETURN TO THE
HOME OF THE PARENTS HE STAYED
AT THE YOUTH SHELTER UNTIL HE
MET AN ATTORNEY FROM BAY AREA
LEGAL EIGHT. WE REVIEW THE
EVIDENCE INVESTIGATED THE STOCK
AND CONCLUDED THAT TIED TO BE
ENTERED INTO FOSTER CARE AND IT
SHOULD HAPPEN IMMINENTLY. DUE
TO HIS AGE OF SEVENTY. HELP YOU
WORKING TO FIVE A TICKET TO
CASH. THE ONLY OPTION BUT FOR
AT THE PETITION ACCOUNT. TO ONE
AGAIN YOUR HANDS INTO FOSTER
PERSON TO ABOUT THE AND
INSTITUTIONS CODE THREE TWO
NINE. ONE HOW MANY AGAIN WORKED.
WE PROTECT THE PURSUANT TO
INSTITUTE CODE THREE THIRTY BY.
THE JUVENILE DEPENDENCY COURT
AGREED TO HEAR THE CASE. BUT
THE COUNTY STALLED THE
SCHEDULING OF THE HEARING DUE
TO THE COUNTY SOCIAL WORKERS
LACK OF THE AVAILABILITY.
BETWEEN THE JUVENILE COURT WHEN
IT AVAILABILITY TO COPE AT AND
THE SOCIAL WORKERS AND
AVAILABILITY TYLER'S HEARING
DID NOT TAKE PLACE UNTIL THE
WEEK PRIOR TO ITS EIGHTEENTH
BIRTHDAY. HOWEVER THE JUVENILE
COURT JUDGE BELIEVE TYPE
TESTIMONY AND THE EVIDENCE
SUBMITTED ON HIS BEHALF. AND
ORDERED THE COUNTY TO
ULTIMATELY FILE A PETITION
WITHIN FORTY EIGHT HOURS THEY
COUNTY FILED THE PETITION THE
FOLLOWING WEEK A DETENTION
HEARING TOOK PLACE THE DAY
AFTER. HI WAS PROVISIONALLY
DETAINED AND THE CASE WAS
CONTINUED FOR TUESDAY. WHEN
THAT SECOND DEPENDENCY HEARING
TOOK PLACE ONE DAY PRIOR TO
TIED EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY TYPE
MOTHER SHOWED UP TO THE HEARING
AND OBJECTED TO ANY FURTHER
DETENTION APPLY. THEY COUNTY
MOVED TO DISMISS THE CASE AND
THE COURT AGREED STATING THAT
COULDN'T POSSIBLY MAKE
DISPOSITIONAL FINDING. PRIOR TO
HIS EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY. HI
WITH TAKEN TO A YOU SHELTER
THAT. THING DAY WELL HE WAS
SEVEN YEARS OF AGE. HE HAS
HOMELESS EVER SO. HE HAS FALLEN
INTO. STATING THAT NO ONE
BELIEVES WHAT HAS HAPPENED TO
HIM. HE DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL
AND WOOD UNFORTUNATELY THE
VICTIM OF A- VIOLENT ROBBERY
ALL DIRECTLY FOLLOWING THE
COURT'S DECISION. TO THIS DAY.
HI HAD DIFFICULTY SPEAKING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AND
CONTINUE TO FEEL COMPLETELY
LEFT BEHIND BY A SYSTEM THAT
WAS INTENDED TO PROTECT YOU
LIKE CAN. WE CAN PREVENT THIS
FROM HAPPENING TO OTHER GIFTS
BUT THAT THE- THIS CONTINUES TO
BE A CALL. FOR MANY AT THE- AND
OF APPROACHING BAY AREA LEGAL
AID FOR LEGAL ASSISTANCE. MANY
STATES THAT DESPITE SEVERAL CPS
REPORT DURING THE PANDEMIC THEY
HAVE YET TO BE REMOVED FROM
THEIR ABUSIVE HOME AND THEY END
UP STAYING AT HOMELESS YOUTH
SHELTER THAT ARE ONLY DESIGNED
FOR TEMPORARY STATES. IT IS
INCUMBENT UPON US SO TO KNOW
THAT THIS CONTINUES TO HAPPEN
TO OUR CALIFORNIA YOU. TO
PREVENT THIS. THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
MR THANK YOU MISTER PRIME-
OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR OUR NEXT WITNESS
WITNESS IN SUPPORT CAN LUIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIM LEWIS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COALITION FOR YOUTH ONE OF THE
CUTS OUT THERE THAT EIGHTY FIVE
FOUR NINE TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
STAFF FOR THEIR WILD RIGHT NOW
OPETH ON THE BELL AS WELL AS
THE TO GET LEADERSHIP ON THE
PROPOSAL. THE LEGISLATURE HAD
BEEN ADAMANT AT SUPPORTING
YOUNG PEOPLE DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND THE NEGATIVE
OUTCOMES THAT UNFORTUNATELY
COME WITH. CHALLENGES AND EVEN
PRESIDENT HAD TIME AND I HOPE
THAT. THE COMMITTEE CAN SEE IT
IN. AND THEIR ABILITY TO
SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL WHICH AT
THE TIME LIMITED SOLUTIONS YOU
REALLY MITIGATE THE IMPACT OF.
THE PANDEMIC AND HELP ARE
REALLY MOST VULNERABLE YOUNG
PEOPLE SO THEY DON'T END UP
HAVING AT AND IF YOU BIRTH THAT
RELIEF YOU'VE BEEN CONTINUING
TO LIVE ON. THE STREET. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU MISS
LEWIS. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE RTS ROOM. OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON THE LINE.
THANK YOU TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
OF. THIS BILL ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ON YOUR PHONE
AGAIN THAT'S ONE OF THEM ZERO
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE
FOUR NINE. JEFF THIS TIME THERE
ARE NO LINES IN Q. THANK YOU
OPERATOR. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE OPERATOR. I BELIEVE THAT
WE DEAL. THANK YOU. DO WE KNOW
IF KERRY ARE HENRY WILL BEGIN
WILL GO FIRST- THERE'S NO ORDER
OF PREFERENCE. BALTIMORE PLANS
ARE OPEN BOTH THE WITNESSES MAY
DECIDE THAT. HOW DO YOU KERRY
AND HENRY ARE PRESENT FOR AB
EIGHTY NINE FIRST BEGAN SUPPORT
OF AB EIGHT TO NINE. WELL
YOU'RE RIGHT SO THERE I MISS
READ MY AGENDA MANAGERS SO
THEREFORE THERE ARE NO
WITNESSES ON THE PHONE IN
OPPOSITION. OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR- SEE DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL. SO THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION ONLINE OKAY THANK
YOU- TWO WE HAD TO ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE MEMBERS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS CHAIRPERSON I A I
MAKE A MOTION FOR APPROVAL
SECOND. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY- WE HAVE A MOTION WE HAVE
A SECOND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER STONE.
THANK YOU AND I JUST WANT TO
COMPLIMENT YOU ON THIS BILL AND
SINCE HEARD SOME OPPOSITION TO
THIS WHICH- IS A BIT
INFURIATING THAT. WE HAVE A
PART OF IT IS AN ARTIFACT OF WE
HAVE. SYSTEM SET UP IN SILOS
FOR DEALING WITH THE KIDS AND
THE TENDENCY KIDS WE PUT
ARTIFICIAL BOUNCE AROUND THOSE.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THAT WE
STRUGGLE TO SUPPORT HOMELESS
KIDS AND OTHERS WHO ARE REALLY
STRUGGLING AND THE MORE WE KEEP
THOSE SILOS. AND THE MORE WE
SEGREGATE THOSE SERVICES
MARKETS DROPPED TO THE CRACKS
BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S- JUST
BEFORE EIGHTEEN OR JUST AFTER
EIGHTEEN A CHILD IN NEED AS A
CHILD IN NEED. AND WE CAN'T LET
ARTIFICIAL. BOUNDARIES THAT
HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE. PREVENT
SERVICES FROM BEING APPLIED
WHEN THEY'RE REALLY CLEARLY
NECESSARY SO- IN FULL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR WORK ON THIS MISTER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THE SYSTEM.
REMEMBER DAVIS THANK YOU MISTER
GIBSON I WANT TO THANK YOU AS
WELL. I WANT TO THANK YOU AS
WELL FOR BRING THIS UP- THE
STATS ARE THAT- ONCE A RELEASED
ARE BASICALLY TO ME I CAUGHT
CURBING AT EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW
THE STATS ARE THAT- MAJORITY OF
THEM BECOME HOMELESS. AND THEY
DON'T HAVE THE TOOLS AT THAT
AGE YET SO EXTENDING THIS- IT
IS DEFINITELY WHAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE SO I THINK YOU ON THIS AND
YOU HAVE MY FULL SUPPORT AND
I'D LIKE TO BE A CO AUTHOR AS
WELL IF YOU THREE. THANK YOU
THANK YOU NOTED. OKAY THANK
YOU- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE-
WELL MICHAEL'S I'M SORRY YES NO
VERY SUMMER GIPSON PLEASE CLOSE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- TO MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WITH THEIR KIND
REMARKS AND PREACHING THE CO
AUTHORSHIP OF FROM ONE MEMBER
EXPRESSED THIS BILL- IS VERY
IMPORTANT IT'S ABOUT- THE
FOSTER YOU. WE REALIZE THEY'VE
BEEN DEALT A TOUGH HAND JUST
BECAUSE THEY'RE IN THE FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM I AM VERY I'M
SADDENED BY TIES I'M SITUATION
HAD TO GO THROUGH I BELIEVE
THAT- THIS BILL FIVE FOUR NINE
WILL STAND UP FOR NOT ONLY
TIGHT BEFORE OTHERS WHO
POSSIBLY FALL IN THE SAME
SITUATION. AGAIN THIS PANDEMIC
WILL BE WITH US ALL WAYS BUT
WHILE IT'S HERE WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DON'T FALL THROUGH THE
CRACKS I THINK IT'S OUR
OBLIGATION AND OUR
RESPONSIBILITY AND I THINK THIS
DEMONSTRATES GOVERNMENT NOT
ONLY AGAINST ANSWERING THE CALL
BUT STANDING UP TO THE CALL-
DURING THIS PARTICULAR TIME
THERE IS WHEN I WAS A POLICE
OFFICER THERE IS A LETTER OF
THE LAW IN THE SPIRIT OF THE
LAW. TODAY'S EXPRESSION OF THE
OF THE LETTER OF THE LAW THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CHANGE SO THAT
BECAUSE THE SPIRIT OF LAW WAS
NOT IMPLEMENTED TO HELP THESE
INDIVIDUALS NOT FALL THROUGH
THE CRACKS WE HAVE THIS POLICY
THAT WILL BE THE LETTER A TO
TWO THOUSAND AND. TWENTY THREE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I
VOTE. THANK YOU GIPSON
SECRETARY. KOBACH THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES. DAVIES
I ARAMBULA. CHOI HI CHOI I
GIPSON AYE GIPSON AYE STONE.
STONE I BILL APPROVED. BY THE
PUT OUT I MOORED. LORD HI THANK
YOU. THE BILL IS SEVENTY ZERO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND WILL
LEAVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. OKAY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LEVINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT.
ALL. HI THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS AB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE WILL IMPROVE
SERVICES TO UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER
YOUTH BY BETTER IDENTIFYING AND
STANDARDIZING ACCESS TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
ACROSS THE STATE THE FEDERAL
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS WAS CREATED TO HELP
ABUSED AND NEGLECTED NEGLECTED
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN OBTAIN
LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENCY IN
THE UNITED STATES IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE GREATER STABILITY TO
THIS VULNERABLE POPULATION THIS
RELIEF IS DIFFICULT TO OBTAIN
WITHOUT LEGAL ASSISTANCE. AB
EIGHT TWENTY NINE REQUIRES
COUNTIES TO PROVIDE INFORMATION
TO THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES REGARDING
CURRENT PROCEDURES IN PLACE TO
SUPPORT UNDOCUMENTED MINOR AND
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS IN FOSTER
CARE UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
THE JUVENILE COURT AND THEIR
PROCESSES TO PROVIDE THESE
YOUTH WITH IMMIGRATION
RESOURCES AB EIGHT TWENTY NINE
ALSO REQUIRES COUNTIES TO MAKE
BEST EFFORTS TO PROVIDE
UNDOCUMENTED COMMITTED MINOR OR
NON MINOR DEPENDENTS IN FOSTER
CARE UNDER THE JURISDICTION OF
THE JUVENILE COURT WITH ACCESS
TO IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
MEMBERS. WE ALL WANT OUR FOSTER
YOUTH TO BE SUCCESSFUL FOR
UNDOCUMENTED FOSTER YOUTH THIS
MEASURE IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS HELPING THEM OBTAIN
LAWFUL RESIDENCY PURSUE THEIR
GOALS AND CONTRIBUTE TO THE
FUTURE OF CALIFORNIA ARE STUCK
THEY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER NINE-
OPERATORS- CAN WE PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE FOR FIRST WITNESS.
PLEASE KERRY WHITE. THE LINE IS
OPEN YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
MY NAME IS KERRY WHITE AND I AM
AN IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY WITH
CHILDREN'S LAW CENTER OF
CALIFORNIA CLC IS A NONPROFIT
LEGAL SERVICES ORGANIZATION
THAT SERVES AS THE VOICE IN THE
FOSTER CARE SYSTEM FOR
DEPENDENT CHILDREN AND HE- OUR
ATTORNEYS AND OTHER
PROFESSIONALS STAFF REPRESENT
OVER THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
ABUSED. AND NEGLECTED CHILDREN
IN THE LOS ANGELES SACRAMENTO
IN PLASTER COUNTY FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. IN ADDITION TO
APPEARING ON BEHALF OF CLIENTS
AND DATED A DEPENDENCY
PROCEEDINGS. GLC PROVIDES
REPRESENTATION AND A HOST OF
RELATED HEARING THAT SEEKS TO
ENSURE THE WELL BEING AND
FUTURE SUCCESS THAT EACH CHILD.
WE THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE.
FOR OFFERING THIS IMPORTANT
LEGISLATION WHICH WILL ENSURE
THEIR PROCESSES IN PLACE TO
PROTECT UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
IN FOSTER CARE. THE VAST
MAJORITY OF UNDOCUMENTED
CHILDREN WHO ENTER THE
DEPENDENCY SYSTEM ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR FORMS OF IMMIGRATION RELIEF
THAT WOULD PUT THEM ON A PATH
TOWARD OBTAINING LAWFUL
PERMANENT RESIDENTS ALSO KNOWN
AS THE GREEN CARD. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE MENTIONED
CONGRESS RECOGNIZED THE UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCES AND
VULNERABILITIES UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH AND IN RESPONSE
CREATED A SPECIFIC FORM OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR THE FEW
WHO ARE UNABLE TO REUNIFY WITH
A PARENT CALLED SPECIAL
IMMIGRANT JUVENILE STATUS.
WHICH IS ITSELF A PATH TOWARDS
LAWFUL PERMANENT RESIDENT. I'M
DOCUMENT CHILDREN WHO LEAVE THE
DEPENDENCIES WITHOUT OBTAINING
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS OR SOME OTHER FORM OF
IMMIGRATION RELIEF WILL BE
UNABLE TO LAWFULLY WORK FOR
TRANSITION SUCCESSFULLY TO
ADULTHOOD. HOWEVER THERE ARE
CURRENTLY NO REQUIREMENTS IN
PLACE TO ENSURE THAT THESE
UNITS ARE IDENTIFIED AND LINKED
WITH IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDER TO ASSIST THEM IN
OBTAINING IMMIGRATION RELIEF.
AS A RESULT THE LEVEL OF
ASSISTANCE TO YOU RECEIVED ON
THEIR IMMIGRATION MATTER VARIES
FROM COUNTY TO COUNTY. SAMPLE
IN COUNTY SUCH AS SACRAMENTO
OUR LAWYERS ARE TYPICALLY THE
ONES SEARCHING FOR AN
IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY OR
NONPROFIT TO REPRESENT OUR
CLIENTS. IN COMPARISON LOS
ANGELES THE CHILD WELFARE
AGENCY WORKS CLOSELY WITH OUR
ATTORNEYS TO IDENTIFY LOCAL
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS AND PRO
BONO ATTORNEYS WHO WILL PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES FOR
OUR CLIENTS. WE HAVE ALSO HEARD
ACCOUNTS OF OTHER COUNTIES
WHERE NO IMMIGRATION LEGAL
SERVICES ARE OBTAINED AND AS A
RESULT USED. TO NOT REPEAT THE
IMMIGRATION RELIEF TO WHICH
THEY ARE. AND WE THE FARM CARE
TO WITHOUT IMMIGRATION. UNDER
CHILDREN IN. HE SAID ALL FACE
AND NOT OF HER. AS THREE
BILLION THE TO WOULD LOW TO NO
IN FOR. OR DOC. ABOUT THEIR-
STATUS. EVEN THEY ARE IN
REMOVAL OR DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS. EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY NINE WILL REQUIRE THE
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE AGENCIES
HAVE A PROCESS IN PLACE TO
IDENTIFY AND TRACK UNDOCUMENTED
FOSTER YOUTH IN THEIR COUNTIES.
IT WILL REQUIRE THAT THE
AGENCIES MAKE BEST EFFORTS TO
LINK THESE CHILDREN TO
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND IF NECESSARY
IDENTIFY ANY GAPS IN SERVICES
AND SUPPORT. ALL OF THESE
MEASURES ARE AIMED AT ENSURING
THAT UNDOCUMENTED POSTURE YOU
TO NOT FALL THROUGH THE CRACKS
AND ARE ABLE TO ACCESS THE
IMMIGRATION RELIEF FOR WHICH
THEY ARE SO FREQUENTLY ELIGIBLE
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
IMPORTANT LEGISLATION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU MISS WHITE
OPERATOR PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR OUR NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT
HENRY MONTANA. THANK YOU ON THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU- MY
NAME SKINNER MANZANA- I'M A
FOSTER YOU FORMER FOR SEE YOU I
INTO. PARENTS WERE NOT ABLE TO
PROVIDE ME WITH THE CARE I NEED
IT I SPENT SO MUCH TIME IN
FOSTER CARE LIVING IN GROUP
HOMES AT SOME POINT DURING MY
TIME IN FOSTER CARE BY COUNTY
SOCIAL WORKER REALIZED THAT I
NEEDED TO MAKE RATIONS
DISTANCE. I WAS BORN A CRIME
WHAT IN MY PARENTS BROUGHT ME
TO UNITED STATES WHEN I WAS
TWELVE YEARS OLD AS A RESULT I
WAS LINKED WITH ANDREAS HOW
MOST INSPIRED SOUTHWESTERN LOT
IMMIGRATION SCHOOL. CLINIC
SORRY. WHO WAS ABLE TO HELP
MEDIATE WITH APPLICATIONS TO
FILE WITH THE GOVERNMENT TO A-
FOR SPECIAL IMMIGRATION
JUVENILES. GIVEN OUR STYLE THIS
PIECE- BECAUSE I DO NOT. RIGHT-
REUNIFY WITH EITHER OF MY
PARENTS. I WAS GRANTED A VISA
AND AFTER THAT I WAS ABLE TO
OBTAIN A GREEN CAR AFTERWARDS
BUTTONS RAMOS HELP. HAVING A
GREEN CARD ENABLES ME TO PURSUE
MY GOALS I WANT TO ACHIEVE IN
MY FUTURE. I AM CURRENTLY
ATTENDING AND LOS ANGELES-
COLLEGE TO OBTAIN A CERTIFICATE
IN MEDICAL ASSISTANCE HOPE TO
BECOME. A REGISTERED NURSE. I
ALSO WORK AS A CARE TAKER TO
HELP ME KEEP WITH MY EX ROM
EXPENSES. WITHOUT ME GRAYSON
STATUS GETTING A JOB IN
ATTENDING COLLEGE I'VE BEEN BUT
STEP OF MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
HAVING IMMIGRATION STATUS HAS
ALLOWED ME TO OBTAIN THINGS
LIKE I. D. WORKMAN A BANK
ACCOUNT AND A SOCIAL SECURITY
CARD. I HONESTLY DO NOT KNOW
WHERE I WOULD BE TODAY IF I DID
IF I HAVE WHAT I DID NOT
RECEIVE THE HELP THAT I GOT. AB
EIGHT NINE CORE- HELP INSURE
THAT OTHER FOSTER YOUTH LIKE ME
ARE LINKED TO THEIR SYSTEM THAT
THEY NEED TO OBTAIN IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IF TRANSITION
SUCCESSFULLY OUT OF FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM BECAUSE OF THIS I AM
HERE TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THIS BILL. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MR MONTANA DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE
ROOM. DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE RTS ROOM. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON
THE LINE. OPERATOR TO EXPRESS
YOURSELF THANK YOU IT TO
EXPRESS SUPPORT FOR A BI EIGHT
TO NINE ME PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN
THAT'S ONE AND THEN ZERO PLEASE.
THANK YOU KNOW LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU OPERATOR OPERATOR DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE. I JUST
WANT TO CLARIFY MANAGER THAT
THIS IS- I DON'T HAVE ANYONE.
REGISTERED IN OPPOSITION DO YOU
WANT TO GO TO PUBLIC YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU IF YOU'D LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION OF AB EIGHT
TWO NINE YOU MAY PRESS THE ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE ZERO
PLEASE. AND THERE ARE NO LAND
IN Q. OKAY THANK YOU OPERATOR.
DO WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THE AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE.
MISTER GIBSON. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH JUST HAVE A BRIEF COMMENT
ONE THANK YOU OFTEN BRING THIS
FOR THANK YOU FOR STANDING UP-
FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED MINORS- I
KNOW YOU'VE BEEN WORKING
EXTREMELY HARD IN THIS SPACE
AND- I WOULD CERTAINLY- ENJOY
IF YOU CAN ADD ME AS A CALL OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT I WOULD
LOVE TO BE ABLE TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL. MOVING FOR I THINK IS THE
RIGHT DIRECTION I'M NOT THINK
THAT ALSO ARE YOU KNOW
ARMIGEROUS IS GOING THIS IN
THIS PARTICULAR DIRECTION BUT
WE NEED TO STAND UP AND I THINK
THIS BILL IS ABSOLUTELY STAND
UP FOR THOSE YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU. IN SURE I
HAVE A QUESTION GO AHEAD MR
CHIA. YEAH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE- I ADMIRE BUT THE SPIRIT
OF THIS BILL I TRIED TO HELP
WELL- CHILDREN AND- THE SUMMARY
OF ANALYSIS OF SAYS UP. TO
CREATE THE CRATERS TO CAREER
GRANTS PROGRAMS TO ADDRESS
CHILD POVERTY AND ACHIEVEMENT
GAP AMONG THE AMONG THE
CHILDREN UP WITH DIFFERENT
RACES AS A SOCIO ECONOMIC
STATUS. AND- I DIDN'T FIND MUCH
OF THIS OF BILL FOCUSES UPON
UNDOCUMENTED- AND ALSO FOSTER
CHILDREN I AM ORDER IN SUPPORT
ALL FOR HELPING. CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE. AND THEN ALSO- OF
PEOPLE IN THIS SITUATION. ALL
IT IS- IN OWN. A LITTLE BIT OF
A CONCERN EVEN SO THIS IS OUR-
HUMANITARIAN- APPROACH TO HELP.
OUR CHILDREN WHO ARE IN NEED.
AS YOU KNOW ALL RIGHT NOW. IN
THE SOUTHERN BORDER OF- A LOT
OF WORK ON A COMPANY TO
CHILDREN ARE CROSSING THE
BORDER SO LITERALLY. THOUSANDS
A DAY. AND THE MOST THEY ARE
HEROES. OBVIOUSLY THERE WILL
NEED TO HELP A SOUL. CONTINUOUS
POLICIES SELECT IS- OPEN ENDED
INVITATION. I KNOW- IMMIGRATION
ISSUE IS A FEDERAL ISSUE. AND
OUT OF WHICH OBVIOUSLY TO TAKE
CARE OF ALL THE PEOPLE IN THE
STATE TO WHO ARE IN NEED A- SO
I'M REALLY TORN BETWEEN. YOU
KNOW. WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
MADRE THE SITUATION. IF YOU
WERE IN THE POSITION TO HANDLE.
WE SHOULD OPEN UP THE OLD.
BULLDOZE. FOR CHILDREN WHO NEED
TO COME TO. THE U. S. AND ONCE
THEY ARE HERE. PROVIDE ALL
THEIR NEEDS ARE GREATER TO
CAREER. OUR MAYES SO UNTIL THEY
BECOME INDEPENDENT. BUDGET THE
HEARING IN THE CASE OF PATIENTS
A SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS SO-
ALLOCATION FOR IMPLEMENTATION
OF THE PLAN. I DON'T KNOW HOW
LONG THIS WILL LAST. BUT I
THINK THIS IS A VERY ON THE
ESTIMATED BUDGET. THAT WOULD BE
TO TAKE CARE OF ALL THE PEOPLE
EVEN IN CALIFORNIA ALONE. WOULD
BE INTO SEVERAL HUNDRED
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. TO ALL
THOSE SO- EDUCATION K. TO
TWELVE AND THEN ALSO COLLEGE
EDUCATION ARE THERE HOUSING
FOOD. SO OPEN ENDED. EARNED OFF
WITH THE MOOD. DO YOU TO GET
THE NECESSARY GRANT A FORMER
GENERAL FUND OR WANT TO RETURN
TO THE FINAL. HAVE YOU THOUGHT
ABOUT THE WHOLE- THE NUMBER
EXACT NUMBER OF THE PEOPLE AND
THE FROM CRADLE MEANS SO IF
THEY RE BORN HERE THE OPERATOR
TO CAREER. SO IF THEY ARE
BABIES ARE BORN HERE THEY ARE
THE U. S. IS CITIZENS YEAH SO
ARE YOU ARE YOU HI IN THE
BEGINNING I DIDN'T HAVE ANY
TROUBLE OR SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
BUT NOW. THERE'S A FOCUS IS ALL
ON ONE ONE DOCUMENTED THAT
CHILDREN. SO FAR OBVIOUSLY.
THIS SUBRING SOFTBALL TOTALLY
DIFFERENT. AND ALL POLICY ISSUE.
SO I WONDER IF YOU CAN COMMENT
ON YOUR THOUGHTS SO WHEN THE
FEW THINGS THAT I HAVE
MENTIONED THANK YOU MISTER TO I
THINK ACTUALLY I WILL BE
DISCUSSING- AB NINE THIRTY TWO
NEXT I THINK THAT'S YES THE
BILL THAT YOU'RE ACTUALLY
COMMENTING ON BUT RIGHT NOW
WE'RE STILL ON. AB. EIGHT
TWENTY NINE. YES SO- SO FIRST
OF ALL YEAH THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CLIMB FROM EIGHTY TO
TWENTY NINE. HI IF THERE AREN'T
ANY OTHER- MEMBERS THAT WANT TO
MAKE ANY COMMENTS- BUT I DO
WANT TO JUST RESPOND VERY
QUICKLY TO DOCTOR CHOI. I'VE
NOT SEEN LEVINE- AND THEN I'M I
AM PRESENTING EIGHT TWENTY
NINE. AND THIS IS FOR CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA. WHO ARE VICTIMS
OF ABUSE OR NEGLECT ALL
CHILDREN IN CALIFORNIA. I AND
THEN WE CAN TALK ABOUT EIGHTY
NINE THIRTY TWO AFTERWARDS. AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU VERY OF THE
ROLE SO I MISSED. A SECOND
PHONE NUMBER MOTIONS A SECOND.
THANK YOU. THE MOTION IS THE
PAST TO THE ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE CALDERON I CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
CHOI. NOT FORTY TURNOUT VOTING
GIPSON- GIPSON AYE STONE AYE
STONE AYE AND FILOPODIA I LIVID
AYE MORTON'S FORD HI. IT'S SIX
TWO ZERO THANK YOU MEASURE
PASSES THANK YOU VERY MUCH I'M
SURE MEMBERS YOU'RE WELCOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEVINE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO- PRESENT NINE. YES
PLEASE. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO WOULD
ESTABLISH THE CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT PROGRAM FOR THE PURPOSE
OF ADDRESSING CHILD POVERTY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG
CALIFORNIA CHILDREN OF
DIFFERENT RACES AND SOCIO
ECONOMIC STATUSES. KOBE
NINETEEN HAS HIGHLIGHTED
INEQUALITIES ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA ONE GROUP MOST
AFFECTED BY THE REPERCUSSIONS
OF COVERT NINETEEN ARE OUR
CHILDREN AND STUDENTS. WITH
CHILDHOOD POVERTY RATES ON THE
RISE IN ALREADY LARGE
EDUCATIONAL ACHIEVEMENT GAPS
WIDENING IN MANY COMMUNITIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA IT IS OUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO INTRODUCE
LEGISLATION TO TACKLE THESE
ISSUES. LOCAL LEADERS HAVE
IMPLEMENTED CRADLE TO CAREER
APPROACHES THAT HAVE BROUGHT
ABOUT MEANINGFUL
TRANSFORMATIONS THAT ADDRESS
POVERTY IN COMMUNITIES ACROSS
CALIFORNIA. THESE APPROACHES
USE COORDINATED INTERVENTIONS
THAT PIVOTAL STAGES OF CHILD
DEVELOPMENT FROM BEFORE BIRTH
THROUGH COLLEGE AND CAREER TO
HELP ENSURE THE CHILD SUCCESS
REGARDLESS. OF HER FAMILY'S IF
CODE SOCIO ECONOMIC STATUS
LANGUAGE PROFICIENCY OR SPECIAL
EDUCATION STATUS EIGHTY NINE
THIRTY TWO WOULD TAKE THESE
LOCAL APPROACHES AND STREAMLINE
THEM. INTO A STATEWIDE
INITIATIVE IMPLEMENTATION OF
EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO WILL
REDUCE CHILD POVERTY AND
ACHIEVEMENT GAPS AMONG CHILDREN
IN CALIFORNIA BY REQUIRING THE
DEPARTMENT OF COMMUNITY
SERVICES AND DEVELOPMENT TO
ADMINISTER THE CRADLE TO CAREER
GRANT PROGRAM. THE EXPANSION OF
THESE PROVEN AND SUCCESSFUL
COMPETITIVE GRANT PROGRAMS IS A
LOW COST WAY TO ENSURE CHILDREN
RECEIVE THE SERVICES THEY NEED
FROM CRADLE TO CAREER I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR LEVINE-
OPERATOR CAN WE OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE FIRST WITNESS IN
SUPPORT AT THIS CRISTINA COUNTY
ALTHOUGH. ALL THE LINE IS OPEN
YOU MAY BEGIN. GREETING THEM
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS HEATING UP IT'S JUST
SOMETHING I GO AND I AM THE
COULD NOT SECURITY POLICY
DIRECTOR. FOR GRADES AND CHILD
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA COULD ARTICULATE
COALITION. OTHER ORGANIZATION
ARE IMPORTANT PART OF ASSEMBLY
BILL NINE THREE TWO. QRADAR
SECURITY COMMUNITIES HAVE A
LOCAL INFRASTRUCTURE THAT
SUPPORTS THE COORDINATION AND
ALIGNMENT OF ALL SERVICES BEING
PROVIDED WITH AN ENTIRE
COMMUNITY AND COUNTY. THE CLEAN
UP YOUR CURRENT LOCAL
CONSTRUCTION IS ASSIGNED TO
BRING PROVIDERS FROM VARIOUS
SECTORS TO WORK TOGETHER AND
TRY AGAIN TO FIGHT THE
SERVICEMEN THAT THE PROVIDE. IF
INSURANCE BETTER SERVICE
DELIVERY DECLINE ALWAYS
STRICTLY CATION OF SERVICES AND
IT'S VERY COST EFFECTIVE. WE
HAVE TRANSPARENT FROM THE
ACCOUNTABILITY. ALL SERVICE
PROVIDERS ARE REQUIRED TO SHARE
THEIR ORGANIZATIONAL DATA IT
HELPS CRADLE TO GRAVE
COMMUNITIES EFFICIENTLY PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THOSE IN NEED. HE
ALSO USE LOCAL DATA AND THAT
THE BIG SPIRITS AS OTHER
CLIENTS TO DEVELOP PROGRAMMING
AND MILESTONES. THE DATA IS
USED TO INFORM CRADLE TO CAREER
CAN BE ACHIEVED OF BEST
PRACTICES THAT CAN BE SCALED UP
OR IMPROVED. IN ADDITION THE
USER DATA TO INFORM LOCAL
POLICY DECISIONS AND TRANSFORM
SYSTEM BY A TEN DEFINING AND
CHANGING POLICIES AND
PRACTICES. FROM ANTIQUITY LANDS
WITH THE EXPLICIT INTENTION OF
DISMANTLING SYSTEMIC RACISM
EMBEDDED IN COMES ARE
PRACTICED. WE HAVE A PROVEN
TRACK RECORD OF REDUCING
DISPARITIES AND CLOSING GAPS IN
EDUCATIONAL OUTCOMES BY
BRIDGING OF THEIR EARLY
CHILDHOOD ZERO TWO FIVE PROGRAM.
K. THROUGH TWELVE AND POST
SECONDARY INSTITUTIONS WITHIN
THE WHOLE CHILD WHOLE FAMILY
COMMUNITY DRIVEN APPROACH. THAT
HAS A PEOPLE CENTERED DESIGN.
CRADLE TO TREATCOMMUNITIES
CREATE LONG TERM SUSTAINABLE
SYSTEM THAT OUR COMMUNITY
CENTER. THANK YOU JEAN IN A TWO
GENERATION APPROACH THEY ARE
MEETING THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF
FAMILIES AND COMMUNITY MEMBERS
THAT ARE DIRECT HELP FROM THE
PUBLIC. WHILE ENSURING THAT
THEIR CHILDREN HAVE THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO GROW
INTO A THRIVING ADULT. LONG
BEFORE CALL THERE ARE THIRTEEN
COMMUNITIES OF PROMISE
NEIGHBORHOODS AND CRADLE TO
GRAVE COMMUNITIES. I THINK
EQUITY GAPS IN COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR. DURING COLD IT BE WERE
ABLE TO STRENGTH IN SERVICE
DELIVERY AND AVOID INTERRUPTION
WHAT THE STATE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS AND MET THE ELEVATED
CALLED THE NINETEEN RELATED
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY. IF YOU
WANTED PARDEE AND ARE LAST
LIFETIME. AND IN THE CRADLE TO
CAREER GRANT PROGRAM IS
NECESSARY- WE URGE YOUR
EYEBALLS FUNKY BEAT NINE THIRTY
TWO. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU MISS SANTIAGO
OPERATOR CAN YOU. PLEASE CALL
THE NEXT WITNESS IN SUPPORT-
MISTER ACTOR TRAVIS. THANK YOU
THAT LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. READING MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
ADVERTISEMENTS I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF HAYWARD
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOOD.
INITIATIVE AT CAL STATE EAST
BAY BUT A DOZEN PARTNERS THAT
ESTABLISHED ONE OF THE FIRST
PROMISE NEIGHBORHOODS IN OUR
STATE. OUR COALITION OF PRIVATE
NEIGHBORHOOD DISTRICTS AGAIN
THE PARTNER SUPPORT THE CRADLE
TO CAREER GRANT PROGRAM. AB
NINE THREE TWO AND TAKE A
FAMILY MEMBER LEVINE FOR
OFFERING HIS BILL. WE BELIEVE
THAT THE SOLUTIONS FOR
ALLEVIATING CHILD AND FAMILY
POVERTY ALREADY EXISTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. AB NINE THREE TWO
AND THAT'S IN BACKBONE
OPERATIONS OF SERVICES TO
COORDINATE DATA DRIVEN RESEARCH
BASED STRATEGIES. THE
CHILDREN'S OUTCOMES THE
NEIGHBORHOODS HARDEST HIT BY
DECADES DECADES OF
DISINVESTMENT. WE BELIEVE THAT
THE SMALLEST RECONNAISSANCE
STRATEGY TO STREAMLINE SERVICES
SAVE MONEY OVER TIME. FOR
EXAMPLE OUR PARTNERS DEALERSHIP
BASKET HEALTH CENTER CHANGE
RESIDENTIAL COOLEY ATTACK AND
NANCY DOESN'T COME FROM A
THOUGHT IT'S TRUSTED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CARE WORKERS WENT DOOR
TO DOOR TRICK FOR HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES TO COVER NINETEEN
MEDICAL. SCHOOL AND ECONOMIC
RESOURCES. COMMUNITY HEALTH
CARE ARE APPROVING SAVINGS. FOR
USE ACROSS COUNTRY WITH THE
RETURN ON INVESTMENT AS HIGH AS
FOUR DOLLARS PER DOLLAR
INVESTED. EVERY CRAB GRASS IN
THE PLACENTA FARMWORKERS IN THE
FIRST AND ONLY FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE IN MY FAMILY. I BELIEVE
AB NINE THREE TWO CAN CHANGE
GENERATIONAL OUTCOME FOR PEOPLE
LIKE ME ARE NOT AN EXCEPTION.
BUT REALIZED IT SHOULD BE ON
FOR THE TRANSLATE. THANKS THAT
REQUIRE BATTLED DEPRESSION TO
MY. BY NAVIGATING OWN ACTED IT
ACADEMIC AND FINANCE THAT ARE.
STAFFORD THE REST. I WORRY
ABOUT MY MOM MOTHER. UNEMPLOYED
AND TAKING ANTI DEPRESSANTS.
WHICH ONE VISIT TO LOS ANGELES
COUNSELING SERVICES IN HAYWARD
FOR TO ACCESS LONG AS RESOURCES
AND EVENTUALLY DROPPING HER
MEDICATIONS. ENTERING AS A PEER
MENTAL HEALTH SPECIALIST. WE'RE
CHEN I THREE NINETY TWO
PREVENTIVE SOLUTION THAT COULD
IN THE TO BE READY FOR
CHILDREN. SO THEY CAN FOCUS ON
LEARNING INSTEAD OF TAKING ON
THE ECONOMIC STRESS OTHER
FAMILIES. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER THOMAS. DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
NOW WE HAVE AN ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE RGS ROOM. YEAH
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE. ALL THANK YOU TO EXPRESS
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT FOR AB NINE
THREE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. IN THE
COMMANDOS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
HERE AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ON THE
LINE. HE LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR THIS BILL YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
THANK YOU THERE ARE NO LINES IN
Q. OKAY- DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION IN RTS ROOM.
OKAY ARE THERE IS THERE ANYONE
ON THE LINE FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
TO OPPOSITION IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY DO ANY OF THE COMMITTEES
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
LEVINE FIRST ONE STOP SAYING I
WILL BE SUPPORTING YOUR BILL I
JUST HAD A QUESTION OF THE BILL
REQUIRES DEPARTMENT TO PUT
TOGETHER WORKING GROUP TO
DEVELOP THE METRICS. AND WHO
SHOULD BE AWARDED THIS GRANT
I'M CAN YOU DESCRIBE TO ME OF
WHO THESE INDIVIDUALS WOULD BE
HOW THE SENATE AS WELL AS- WHAT
TYPE OF BACKGROUND EXPERIENCE-
DO YOU ENVISION SITTING ON THE
SUPPORT- AND ALSO YOUR
INTERESTING QUESTION- THE CREEK
CRADLE TO CAREER- GRANT PROGRAM
IS REALLY INFORMED BY SOMETHING
THAT'S GROWN FROM OUR
COMMUNITIES- AND SO THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT- THE
DEPARTMENT WILL BE BORROWING
OR- SEEKING ASSISTANCE FROM
HE'S PROVEN LOCAL MODELS FROM
OUR OWN COMMUNITIES THAT. HAVE
BEEN SUCCESSFUL. IS THERE IT IS
THERE SOMETHING THAT I WAS THE
AYE I SEE GOING WITH THE MODEL
MAY BECOME COMING FROM YOURSELF
DESERVE YOU DOES ANYTHING THAT
YOU WOULD SEE LIKE HOW YOU
WOULD WANT TO SEE SITTING ON
THE BOARD WHICH I THINK SUPPORT
THAT WOULD MAKE THAT UP. WELL I
THINK WE HEARD FROM WITNESSES
THAT THAT REALLY ARE INFORMED
ABOUT WHAT'S HAPPENING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES. WE'RE SO WE'RE
REALLY TRYING TO HAVE- SAFE AND
HEALTHY COMMUNITIES THAT THAT
CHILDREN CAN BE RAISED IN AND
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE THAT
THAT HAVE. THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED AND THESE ARE THE
LOCAL MODELS THAT NO BETTER
THAN I THINK. ME IS JUST ONE
LAWMAKER- CAN DECIDE- ON MY OWN
BUT BUT THESE ARE. KIND OF THE
EXEMPLARS RIGHT AND- AND I
THINK WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
EXCELLENT WORK THAT'S HAPPENING
IN THE COMMUNITY. THAT'S REALLY
THE SEED FROM WHICH THIS BILL.
WAS PLANTED AND BORN FROM.
THANK YOU HAS TO BE ON. SURE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO GO HAVE YEAH
OKAY BACK TO ALL REFER HER
RIGHT NUMBER OF JUST FOUR SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF WHAT TWO
YEAR PROGRAM- YEAH I FIND IT
TOUGH HAVE YOU IDENTIFIED ON
NUMBER OF- CHILDREN WHO WOULD
BE GETTING THE BENEFIT OF THIS
BEYOND THAT'S THE NUMBER ONE
QUESTION NUMBER TWO QUESTION
IS- NOW YOU TALK ABOUT THE
HELPING OUT WITH THIS A GRANT-
DO CHIPMAN GAP IN THE SCHOOL-
HOW DO YOU DEFINE ACHIEVEMENT
GAP- BUT SHE GRADE TO DEGRADE
THE L. HALL. WHAT KIND A SCHOOL
OR GRADE THE ALL PERFORMSO
WILL BE A SELF TO OF WHAT. WELL
I THINK YOU'RE YOU'RE INTEREST
AS A PRE- I THINK THE GRAND. IS
ALSO APPRECIATED- AS FAR AS THE
NUMBERS I THINK THAT THAT'S A
DECISION FOR THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE TO REALLY DETERMINE
WHAT THAT NUMBER WILL
ULTIMATELY BE. IF WE LOOK AT
THE GRAND SCOPE OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WHAT WE SPEND FOR ANTI
POVERTY MEASURES FOR EDUCATION-
WHICH I THINK IS A HUGE ANTI
POVERTY MEASURE RIGHT WE'RE
SPEAKING IN THE THAT TENS AND
TENS OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS UP
MORE THAN THAT RIGHT SO. THIS
IS NOT A LOT OF MONEY- TO TRY
TO IDENTIFY WE'RE WE'RE WE'RE
MAKING GOOD INVESTMENTS AND SO
WE ARE WE ARE INVESTING YOU
KNOW PROBABLY A HUNDRED BILLION
PLUS IF YOU START TO TALK ABOUT
HEALTH CARE AS WELL- SO WE'RE
TRYING TO FIGURE THIS OUT WE
TALK A LOT ABOUT NOT MAKING-
THE LACK OF MAKING. DATA
INFORMED DECISIONS AND THIS IS
JUST A VERY SMALL EFFORT TO DO
THAT- SO I AGAIN I WILL LEAD-
LEAVE THE TO THE DEPARTMENT
AND- THE GRANT MAKING PROCESS
THAT THEY ARE GOING TO BE
CREATING TO REALLY IDENTIFY HOW
TO. DO THAT PASSED I DON'T WANT
TO LEGISLATE EXACTLY HOW IT'S
DONE BECAUSE- THEN THEY'RE
STUCK WITH IT- AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT THE ERRORS OF THAT WAY. SO
ACTUAL IMPLEMENTATION. OR WILL
BE DETERMINED. BASED UPON THE
TARGET NUMBER OF ALL PEOPLE WHO
MAY- BE ABLE TO GET THE
BENEFITS OF FROM THIS- PROGRAM
WELL I WISH THAT WE COULD MAKE
DECISIONS THAT WAY BUT I THINK
THAT WE ARE SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS YOU IDENTIFIED YEAH
BASED UPON WHAT- A DATA HAVE
YOU PROPOSED TO SIXTY MILLION
DOLLARS FOR TWO YEARS SO THIS
IS REALLY GOING TO BE INFORMED
BY THE BUDGET PROCESS THAT THE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU'RE ASKING SO
WE ARE WORKING TOWARDS WHAT IS
THAT RIGHT NUMBER AND HOW MANY
CHILDREN. RIGHT THAT WE'RE
WE'RE SEEKING THE IMPACT WITH
UNDERSTANDING DATA- I DON'T
THINK THE NUMBER OF CHILDREN IS
LIMITED- NECESSARILY BECAUSE
DATA INFORMED DECISION MAKING
THEN LEADS TO BETTER
INVESTMENTS SO I WOULD LIKE TO
THINK THAT WE ARE GOING TO
IMPACT ALMOST ANY CHILD IN
CALIFORNIA THAT'S MY GOAL THIS.
IS I HONESTLY ONE OF MOST
CONSEQUENTIAL BILLS ALL ALL
AUTHOR ON BEHALF OF HELPING
EVERY CHILD REACH HER FULL
POTENTIAL. WHAT WILL YOU BE ON-
BENEFIT- EVERYONE. WHO HAS-
ACHIEVEMENT GAP ACADEMICALLY OR
WOULD THIS BE ON ANY TARGETING
FOR CERTAIN INCOME BRACKET.
WELL I THINK THAT WE'RE LOOKING
TO MAKE DATA INFORMED DECISIONS
ON OUR- ANTI POVERTY AN
ACHIEVEMENT GAP INVESTMENTS SO
WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO
ACCOMPLISH A LOT BEING INFORMED
BY THE DATA AS TO WHAT
INTERVENTIONS ARE THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL ONES IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY. ANY MORE QUESTIONS NOW
OKAY SOME OF LIVING WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE YEAH THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR THIS- IN INFORMED
OF DEBATE AND CONVERSATION I'M
GRATEFUL FOR THE INTEREST IN
THIS ISSUE YOU WANT THE MEMBERS
OF THIS COMMITTEE IF YOU
WEREN'T. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. SECOND CAN WE HAVE
A MOTION AND SECOND US
SECRETARY. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA. CHOI
AYE CHOI AYE GIPSON GIPSON AYE
STONE STONE HI BILL APPROVED BY
THE FOOD I MORE. WORK HI. READ
A SEVEN ZERO. THANK YOU MR
LEVINE THANK YOU VERY MUCH FROM
TURN MEMBERS THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW WOULD YOU
LIKE TO PRESENT.
GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES I'M PROUD
TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
THIRTEEN THIRTY EIGHT WHICH IS
THAT OF HELPING TO ADDRESS THIS
GREAT COURAGEOUS NOTION OF
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME OR
GUARANTEED INCOME AS YOU MAY
KNOW THAT THEIR NUMBER OF
PILOTS THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA A NUMBER OF
CITIES INCLUDING THAT OF
STOCKTON LONG BEACH IN MANY
CITIES IN BETWEEN. CURRENTLY WE
KNOWTHAT THESE PILOTS ARE.
HELPING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
ISSUES RELATED TO THE
DEVASTATION DURING THE COVERED
PANDEMIC AND WE SEE AN
INCREDIBLE RESULTS COME FROM A
NUMBER OF THESE DIFFERENT
PILOTS. UNFORTUNATELY WE MAY
SEE THAT AS SOME OF THESE CASH
PAYMENTS MAY ALSO IMPACT THE
ELIGIBILITY FOR INDIVIDUALS.
WHO MAY BE A PART OF THE TOWERS
ARE CALFRESH BENEFITS PROGRAM
THIS EXEMPTS ANY FUNDS THAT
GUARANTEED INCOME PROVIDES TO
THOSE INDIVIDUALS. WITH ME
TODAY. SPEAKING IN SUPPORT IS
THE MAYOR OF LONG BEACH ROBERT
GARCIA. AS WELL AS THEIR MALALA
FROM THE- SAN FRANCISCO PILOT
ABANDONED BIRTH WHICH PROVIDES
A THOUSAND DOLLARS BASIC INCOME
TO PREGNANT BLACK AND PACIFIC
ISLANDER WOMEN. AS WELL AS JIM
PUGH WITH THE UNIVERSAL INCOME
PROJECT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU SOME NUMBER
BELOW- OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR- MAYOR ROBERT
GARCIA. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH
I'M ALSO A ONE OF OVER FORTY
MAYORS ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT
ARE PART OF THE MAYOR'S FOR
GUARANTEED INCOME OUR PROGRAM
AND WE'RE A GROUP OF MAYORS
THAT REALLY ARE ADVOCATING FOR
ACCURATE INCOME PILOTS ACROSS
THE COUNTRY A WORD STRONG
SUPPORT BOB CAN RELOAD THE
BILL- WE ARE ONE FIFTY PORTENT
FOR US IS TO HAVE AS MUCH
FLEXIBILITY AS POSSIBLE IN
THESE CARE TAKING COMPILERS-
THE CITY OF LONG BEACH HAS
ALREADY LAUNCHED. A ONE PILOT
THEY WERE ACTUALLY IN THE
PROCESS OF EXECUTING RIGHT NOW
FOR OUR LOCAL ARTISTS- AND
WE'RE ALSO IN THE PROCESS OF
PLANNING A MAJOR- PILOTS
TACKLED THE STYLE WE KIND OF
HAD A COUPLE MILLION DOLLARS
FOR AS WELL AS SOME SUPPORT
FROM CONTAMINATIONS- THAT WILL
LOOK AT MEETING BASIC NEEDS FOR
PARKS ACROSS ONE INCH-
POTENTIALLY LOOKING AT CENSUS
TRACKS- THAT. WORKS WHERE THIS
WORLD WERE THE FOLKS THAT ARE
STRUGGLING AND THAT- LUÍT TO
HELP CALL YOU BACK THAT HI
COMMITTEE QUALITY GAS- WE ALSO
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
DEVELOPING THIS PROGRAM AND
IT'S THIS IS LARGER FROM- THAT
RESIDENTS ARE. ABLE TO BE A OF
OUR CAN PROGRAMME ALSO AREN'T
IMPACTED AS RELATES TO- TO. IN
CAL WORK SUPPORT- FOR THOSE OF
US THAT REALLY BLEW THAT-
GEARED COMPARE ALSO CRITICAL TO
CAN IMAGINING. OF THE WAY OUR
CAR AT IS IT CAN AT THE KEY-
THIS CHANGE IS REALLY IS
IMPORTANT WE WANT PEOPLE TO BE
LEFT OUT OF ARGUED CONTROL. AND
IT WOULD HAVE PILOT UP AND DOWN
STATE OF CALIFORNIA- OF THE
COMMITTEE GETS- WE REALLY THAT
CARE TO INCOME IS THE FUTURE SO-
JUST WHICHEVER ASK YOU ARE YOU
GIVE US THE- TO HAVE THIS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK
MAYOR GARCIA- UPPER. PLEASE UP
THE LINE FOR NEXT WITNESS
MISTER. MOM. THEM ALL UP THANK
YOU. THAT LINE IS OPENED. HI
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR THE OTHER
TO THE- MY NAME IS DR. YOU GO
TO OF PUBLIC HEALTH AND I'M
REPRESENTING THE CITY IN COUNTY
OF FRANCISCO TODAY. WE HAD.
INCOME THIS THINK. AT REALLY
ABOUT THE DISAPPEAR AS A THEY
USE RUN ON. LINE AND FAMILY
DON'T HAVE ENOUGH INCOME. TO
MEET THEIR NEEDS IT LIMITS
THEIR OF. TO THRIVE. BUT IT
CAUSES STRESS. AND IMPORTANT WE
RECKON THAT DRESS MAKES THIS OF.
TISSUE HEALTH LIKE COPD. LIKE
HEART DISEASE AND LIKELY BIRTH.
IN FACT RESEARCH IS REALLY MORE
AND MORE THESE DAYS THE THERE
IS A VERY CONNECTION BETWEEN BY.
STE AND POOR HEALTH OUTCOMES.
TODAY MEMBER TODD ABOUT ISSUES
LIKE. CAL WORK AND BASIC INCOME
PILOT. TODD ABOUT ABSTRACT
ECONOMIC POLICY. WE'RE ALSO
TALKING ABOUT RACISM AND WE'RE
DECIDING ABOUT LIFE AND DEATH.
FOR INSTANCE SAN FRANCISCO
WE'RE DEALING WITH A VERY
SERIOUS BLACK MATERNAL HEALTH
CRISIS IN FUNDING FRANK THE
REST OF CALIFORNIA IS ALSO
DEALING WITH THIS BLACK
MATERNAL HEALTH CRISIS. SAN
FRANCISCO BLACK WOMEN ARE TWICE
AS LIKELY TO DIE IN CHILDBIRTH.
AND HE DISPARITIES ARE DRIVEN
BY STRESS AND WHAT COULD BE
MORE STRESSFUL THAN ANNUAL
FAMILY INCOME OF THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR BUT
UNFORTUNATELY THAT IS THE
MEDIAN ANNUAL INCOME FOR BLACK
FAMILIES IN MY CITY OF SAN
FRANCISCO. AND THE CONTEXT YOU
SHOULD KNOW THAT YOU NEED OVER
A HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
ANNUAL INCOME IF YOUR FAMILY
WITH EVEN JUST ONE CHILD
CLEARLY THE COLORS. WERE REALLY
TO REACH THIS LEVEL OF INCOME.
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. WE IN
FRANCISCO WILL LAUNCH ABANDON
OF PRIDE. THI PILOT PROVIDE
BLACK AND ISLANDER PREG PEOPLE
A THOUSAND DOLLARS. THROUGH
THEIR PREGNANCY AND POST. IT'S
ONE OF ANY WONDERFUL INCOME
PILOT THAT HAVE BEEN. A THE
STATE. AND BASIC INCOME PILOTS
ARE GREAT WAY TO STRUGGLING
QUICK. AND COUNTRY. MANY HAVE
TOLD ME THE THEY THINK THOUSAND
A MONTH IT'S A CHEN BEN.
FAMILIES ACROSS CALIFORNIA KNOW
THAT REDUCE IN THE STATE EXTRA
EXPENSIVE. AND EVEN WITH THE
BENEFITS MANY LOOKING THIS TO
MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS. WE MUST
THEREFORE PROTECT CAL WORKS CAL
FRESH BY. OF THESE BASIC INCOME
PARTICIPANTS. THE MAXIMUM THAT
FAMILIES BE COME. IN THE FACE
OF RACE INCOME. A MINIMUM WAGE
THAT IS NOT LIVABLE FROM NINE
ONE ONE INCREASING COSTS FOR
HOUSING IN COLLEGE IN OUR STATE
AND A COMPLETE FAILURE TO
ADDRESS HISTORICAL RACISM IN.
THIS IS LIKE THE NATIVE
AMERICAN GENOCIDE AND
DISPLACEMENT OF THE NATIVE
AMERICAN POPULATION REDLINING
URBAN RENEWAL IN THE FACE OF
ALL OF THESE ISSUES AND
INADEQUATE- ADDRESSING OF
HISTORICAL INJUSTICES FAMILIES
NEED MORE THAN A THOUSAND
DOLLARS A MONTH THE
SUPPLEMENTAL INCOME TO MEET
THEIR BASIC NEEDS. IT DOESN'T
SERVICE AT THE STATE
SYSTEMATICALLY DENY SO MANY
HARD WORKING PARENTS AND THEIR
CHILDREN THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED TO MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS
PLEASE SUPPORT. EIGHTY THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU DOCTOR MY- DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
HI GO AHEAD THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS JIM HUGH I'M A CO
DIRECTOR OF THE UNIVERSAL
INCOME PROJECT. YOU'RE A CO
SPONSOR OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT AND I WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS MY STRONG SUPPORT I AM
ALSO AVAILABLE IF THERE ARE ANY
DETAILED POLICY QUESTIONS
RELATED TO LEGISLATION I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER THEM. THANK YOU.
DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE RTS ROOM. NO
OKAY OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE. DO AND IF THERE ARE
OTHERS YOU MAY PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU FOR THE FIRST ONLINE
ONE NINETY ONE YOUR LINE MAY
HAVE BEEN Q. EARLIER AND IT'S
OPEN NOW. NINE ONE ONE NINETY
ONE DID YOU WANT TO SPEAK
TOWARDS THE BILL YOU QUEUED UP
FOR. BONTA LINE TWO HUNDRED TWO
ZERO ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES
NICOLO DELUCA ON BEHALF OF THE
OAKLAND MAYOR LIBBY SCHAAF'S IN
STRONG SUPPORT REALLY
APPRECIATE THE LEADERSHIP OF
THE AUTHOR THE LOCAL MAYOR IS
ALSO A MEMBER OF MAYORS OF
GUARANTEED INCOME AND WE'RE
PROUD OF OUR PILOT PROGRAMME IN
OAKLAND AND JUST REALLY WANT TO
EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
PINE TO AWAIT TWO HUNDRED
EIGHTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS PER
FORTY DOLLARS ON BEHALF OF THE
CENTER FOR EMPLOYMENT
OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. NINE TWO OH FOUR TWO ZERO
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SABRINA
SANTIAGO AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF GOLDEN STATE
OPPORTUNITY AN ORGANIZATION
THAT WORKS TO PROMOTE FINANCIAL
STABILITY FOR CALIFORNIANS. YES
OF THE COURT AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT AND WE ASK THAT YOU
SUPPORTED AS WELL MY INSURING
THE PUBLIC BENEFITS ARE NOT
IMPACTED BY GUARANTEED INCOME
PILOTS WE CAN SUPPORT FAMILIES
AND INDIVIDUALS. SEEKING TO
BUILD A BETTER FUTURE FOR
THEMSELVES THIS BILL IS AN
IMPORTANT STEP TO DEVELOPING
RESEARCH THAT INFORMS GOOD
POLICY IN RESPONSE TO
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU. NINE TWO
TEN TWO ONE ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS MARKET GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. NINE
TO TWELVE TWO ONE TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
THIS IS MICHELLE DEAL ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN SUPPORT. LINE ONE
SEVENTY FIVE ONE SEVEN FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE ONE SEVEN
FIVE IS YOUR PHONE ON MUTE.
WELL BOND ALIGNED ONE SIXTY TO
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ASSEMBLY MEMBER CALDERON
AND FAMILY MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HUMAN SERVICES
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS SURELY YET
ON WITH MY PASSWORD AFTER THE
CAN NATIONAL NONPROFIT FOCUSING
ON USE FINANCIAL AND ECONOMIC
INCLUSION. WE ARE ALSO PART OF
THE CAN TO CALIFORNIA
GUARANTEED INCOME PILOT
PROJECTS CURRENTLY THE ONLY TWO
IN THE COUNTRY THAT ARE FOCUSED
ON YOUTH TRANSITIONING INTO
ADULTHOOD ONE THE FOSTER YOUTH
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY. AND ONE
FROM YOUNG PARENTS IN AN
FRANCISCO WE ARE IN FULL
SUPPORT. OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
EIGHT THANK YOU. NEXT DEADLINE
ONE EIGHT ONE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
ONE EIGHTY ONE. THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS TERRY ONLY AND WITH
ECONOMIC SECURITY PROJECT
ACTION WE'RE AN ORGANIZATION
FOCUSED ON ECONOMIC JUSTICE BY
LIFTING UP A GUARANTEED INCOME
AND OTHER DIRECT CASH
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS WE HAVE
PARTNERED WITH A NUMBER OF THE
PILOTS ACROSS THE COUNTRY-
INCLUDING SOME OF THOSE WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY. APPEAR IN
STRONG SUPPORT WE URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. GLOBAL LINE ONE
NINETY TWO ONE NINE TWO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY
NAME IS JORDAN SAYS- THE
LEGISLATIVE POLICY MANAGER- OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION AND
A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH THIS
ARTICLE YOU- HAVE BEEN
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACTED
DURING THE ECONOMIC DOWNTURN IN
A PANDEMIC HAS EXACERBATED THE
TRIALS AND TRIBULATIONS
BACKGROUND A FORMER BOSS YOU'VE
HAD- BASED. THERE HAS BEEN
STATE OF FEDERAL SUPPORT FOR
CURRENT AND FORMER BOSS USED TO
MEET IMMEDIATE NEEDS GUARANTEES
PANDEMIC AN ACTIVE ORGANIZATION
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU
DID NOT BATES YEARS OR ARE
PENALIZED TO ACCESS SOCIAL
SERVICES PROGRAMS THAT THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS CALIFORNIA
YOUTH CONNECTION IN SUPPORT OF.
AB THIRTEEN THIRTY. OUR FINAL
LINE IN CUBA'S LINE ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY TWO ONE FIVE TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. HELLO MY NAME IS
GLOBALLY AND THEN WITH THE
CHILDREN'S DEFENSE FUND
CALIFORNIA AND THEN TO SHOW MY
TROUBLE SUPPORT FOR A BI TAKING.
THIRTY AND THEY'RE AN ONLINE IN
SUPPORT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES ON THE LINE IN
OPPOSITION. I'D LIKE TO STATE
YOUR POSITION OF OPPOSITION
FOUR ONE ONE THREE THREE EIGHT
YOU MAY PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ON YOUR PHONE. THANK M. S.
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. THERE ARE
NO LINES TO QUEUE AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY- ONE IN OPPOSITION AND THE
RTS ROOM NOW OKAY- JUST ANY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEES HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU THE MOTION AND A SECOND-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE SOMEONE BELOW. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I WANT TO ALSO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF AS
WELL AS OF A PREVIOUSLY
INTRODUCED THIS LAST YEAR BUT
DURING THE PANDEMIC THIS
COMMITTEE MADE AT THE
COMMITMENT FOR US TO CONTINUE
THE CONVERSATION I WANT TO
SUPPORT LOCAL CITIES AS WELL. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU. SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND- SECRETARY. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES NO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I'D CHOI NO CHOICE NO
GIPSON. GIPSON AYE STONE AYE
STONE I BILL APPROVED BY THE
FOOD AYE AYE WARD. LORD HI.
VERTUS SIXTY TWO OKAY THANK YOU
CONGRATULATE THE VERY MUCH
ALIVE. SOMEONE WHO YOU TO LIKE
TO PRESENT YOUR BILL.
GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL FOUR
NINETY NINE I LEGISLATION WHICH
WILL CREATE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS AT SENIOR CARE
REFERRAL AGENCIES. RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES OR RCF VI'S FOR
THE ELDERLY ARE NON MEDICAL
FACILITIES THAT SPECIALIZE IN
HOUSING PERSONALIZED SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES AND ASSISTANCE AND
ACTIVITIES OF DAILY LIVING.
SUCH AS GETTING DRESSED EATING
WALKING AND SO ON RCF EASE OUR
LICENSE INSPECTED AND REGULATED
BY THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES DURING THE CALL
THE NINETEEN REFER A COMMON
NINETEEN REFERRAL AGENCIES HAVE
BEEN A CRUCIAL PART OF THE
PLACEMENT DECISIONS FOR L.
ELDER AND DEPENDENT ADULT. AS
A- VISITATION IS EITHER NOT AN
OPTION OR INFREQUENT TO LIMIT
THE EXPOSURE OF RESIDENTIAL
STAFF WHEN FAMILY FAMILIES ARE
LOOKING TO PLACE A LOVED ONE IN
AN ART CAF ET THEY OFTEN TURN
TO REFERRAL SOURCES. REFERRAL
SOURCES ARE AGENCIES THAT MATCH
INDIVIDUALS TO AN ASSISTED
LIVING COMMUNITY BASED ON THE
SPECIFIC NEEDS OF THE
INDIVIDUAL THIS SERVICE IS
TYPICALLY AT NO COST TO THE
FAMILY WITH THE REFERRAL SOURCE
BEING ARE WE NUMERATE IT BY THE
FACILITY ITSELF. THIS
LEGISLATION IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
TRANSPARENCY AND ACCESS OF
INFORMATION FOR CONSUMERS
SEEKING PLACEMENT AT A
RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITY. AB
FOUR NINETY NINE SIX TO PROTECT
ALL INTERESTED PARTIES BY COURT
OF CODIFYING THE NUMBER OF
REGULATED REGULATIONS DURING A
REFERRAL SOURCE INTERACTIONS
WITH THE CLIENT AND INCREASE
REGULATIONS ARE REFERRAL
SOURCES NOTABLY AB FOUR NINETY
NINE REQUIRES REFERRAL SOURCES
TO PROVIDE DISCLOSURES TO
SENIORS ORDERED REPRESENTATIVES
SOME OF THE DISCLOSURES INCLUDE
THE REFERRAL SOURCES PRIVACY
POLICY A STATEMENT ON WHETHER
THE REFERRAL SOURCE WILL BE
PAID A REFERRAL FEE BY THERE
ARE C. F. P. TO WHICH THE
SENIOR IS REFERRED TO. AND THE
STATEMENT THAT THE SENIOR OR
REPRESENTATIVES MAY REQUEST IN
WRITING THAT THE REFERRAL
SOURCE FEES CONTACT WITHTHE
SENIOR. OTHER. REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDE THE CONDITIONS THAT
REFERRALS SIMPLY NEED TO
UNDERGO. CHECKS THE MAINTAINING
OF LIABILITY INSURANCE AND ONLY
CAN- CONDUCTING BUSINESS WITH
WRITTEN CONTRACT AB FOUR NINETY
NINE ALSO OUTLINES THE CRITERIA
OF ABUSE AND OR POOR QUALITY OF
A TREATMENT OF TREATMENT FOUND
WITHIN THAT OUR CFE I REFERRAL
SOURCE NEEDING TO BE REPORTED
TO THE APPROPRIATE LICENSING
AGENCY. THE BILL ENJOYS WIDE
SUPPORT AND IS THE RESULT OF
EXTENSIVE STAKEHOLDER MEETINGS
ON THE LINE WITH THE TECLA THAT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF AB FOUR
NINETY NINE ARE MONICA MILLER
AND CLIFF BURKE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOMEONE WOMAN RUBIO.
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE YOU. FOR THE FIRST
WITNESS IN THE QUEUE. I THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR CLOSE BURKE
HEARING BEHALF OF PLACE FOR
MOM- WE ARE A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL ALONG WITH MONICA'S
CLIENT AND WE'RE EACH YEAR
SUPPORT OF AB FOUR NINE NINE
WHICH WOULD ESTABLISH A
TRANSPARENT PROCESS TO ENSURE
THE CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. ARE
PROVIDED WITH THE INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO MAKE AN INFORMED
DECISION AS THEY FIND THE RIGHT
FACILITY FOR FAMILY MEMBERS. A
PLACE FOR MOM IS LARGEST
NATIONAL ONLINE SENIOR LIVING
REFERRAL AGENCY WITH HUNDREDS
OF HIGHLY TRAINED EXPERIENCING
A PASSIONATE SENIOR LIVING
ADVISORS. LOCATED IN CITIES
ACROSS NORTH AMERICA INCLUDING
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA A PLACE
FOR MOM IS COMMITTED TO
PROVIDING FAMILY MEMBERS THE
CRITICAL ASSISTANCE THEY NEED
AND FINDING THE RIGHT ASSISTED
LIVING FACILITY FOR THEIR LOVED
ONE OFTEN A TIME OF CRISIS
BASED ON YOUR UNIQUE NEEDS. AND
BUDGET AB FOUR NINE NINE IS THE
ROLE IS ULTRA OF OVER SIX YEARS
OF LEGISLATIVE DISCUSSIONS
CONTEMPLATING HOW TO PROVIDE
CONSUMERS BENEFIT ORIENTED
NOTICES TO FAMILIES WITHOUT
CREATING UNNECESSARY COSTS ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
WITHOUT CREATING UNDUE BURDENS
ON THE INDUSTRY WELL POSITIVELY
CHANGING THE PLAYING FIELD. FOR
CONSUMERS AND FAMILIES. AFTER
WELL OVER A YEAR AND A HALF OF
NEGOTIATIONS. ON THE BILL. IN
OVER MONTHS OF WORK DIRECTLY
WITH CONSUMER ADVOCATES FOR OUR
C. F. B. REFORM CAR. IN OTHER
STAKEHOLDERS YOU HAVE BEFORE
YOU AND VERSION OF THE BILL THE
STRIKES A- GREAT BALANCE
BETWEEN CONSUMER NOTICE AND
PROTECTIONS WITHOUT IMPOSING
UNDUE BURDENS UPON. THE
BUSINESS COMMUNITY. FOR THE
FIRST TIME I CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL WOULD CREATE STATUTORY
REQUIREMENTS. FOR DISCLOSURES
TO FAMILIES LIMIT CONFLICTS OF
INTEREST AND PROVIDE BACKGROUND
CHECKS IN INSURANCE COVERAGE
MINIMUMS. SPECIFICALLY FOR NINE
NINE WOULD ENACT A NOTICE
REQUIREMENT PROVIDING FAMILIES.
INFORMATION INCLUDING A
DESCRIPTION OF THE REFERRAL
AGENCY SERVICES. CONTACT
INFORMATION INCLUDING EMAIL
ADDRESS MAILING ADDRESS AND
TELEPHONE NUMBER- THE PRIVACY
POLICY OR LINK TO THE PRIVACY
POLICY. INFORMATION ON HOW THE
REFERRAL AGENCIES PAID- AND A
STATEMENT OF THE FAMILY MAY
REQUEST THAT THE REFERRAL
AGENCY CEASE CONTACT WITH THE
FAMILY- AND INFORMATION ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF STATE
INSPECTION AND COMPLAINT. THE
BILL PROVIDES FOR BACKGROUND
CHECKS ON REFERRAL AGENCIES
EMPLOYEES WHO HAVE DIRECT
CONTACT WITH SENIORS REQUIRES
LIABILITY INSURANCE COVER EACH
LIMITS ANY BACKCHANNEL
REMUNERATION TO REFERRAL
AGENCIES. AND REQUIRES THE
REFERRAL AGENCIES TO MAINTAIN
THE PRIVACY POLICY THESE ARE
IMPORTANT CONSUMER DISCLOSURES
AND PROTECTIONS THAT ARE
PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT COVERT
WORLD IN WHICH FAMILIES CAN NOT.
INSPECT OR VISIT THESE
FACILITIES- I WOULD REALLY WANT
TO THANK ASSEMBLY WHEN. RUBIO
FOR STEPPING UP IN CARRYING
THIS BILL TO- FOR THOSE MEMBERS
WHO ARE NOT ON THE COMMITTEE
LAST YEAR FOR THOSE WHO WERE-
TO REMIND YOU THIS BILL WAS
AUTHORED- LAST SESSION MASON
WOMEN IAN CALDERON IT PASSED
COMMITTEE UNANIMOUSLY PASSED
THE ASSEMBLY UNANIMOUSLY- WE
TOOK SOME ADDITIONAL CONSUMER
PROTECTION AMENDMENTS THAT WERE
NEGOTIATED AND SENDING HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE. WE'RE ALSO
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY- WITH BROAD
SUPPORT FROM ALL STAKEHOLDERS
AND UNFORTUNATELY WAS HELD IN
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
SUSPENSE FILE SINCE AUTUMN
WOMEN CALDERON I DO NOT RETURN
TO THIS ALL LEGISLATURE THIS
YEAR AND THIS SOMEBODY WOMAN.
RUBIO WAS THE PRINCIPAL AUTHOR
CO AUTHOR LAST YEAR SHE AGREED
TO PUT THE BILL FORWARD AGAIN
AND WE MUCH APPRECIATE THAT- WE
BELIEVE IT IS AN IMPORTANT BILL
FOR CALIFORNIA CONSUMERS. IT IS
IMPORTANT BILL PROVIDING
DISAPPEAR THE FIRST TIME
REQUIREMENTS FOR THESE KINDS OF
DISCLOSURES BUT IN A WAY THAT
DOES NOT CREATE AN UNREASONABLE
BURDEN OR- IN ANY WAY CHANGE
THE PLAYING FIELD BETWEEN THE
STAKEHOLDERS. WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE THANK
YOU MISTER BERG OP CAN YOU-
OPEN ONLINE FOR NEXT WITNESS
AND SUPPORT MONICA MILLER. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MONICA MILLER ON BEHALF OF ACT
WHICH IS A CO SPONSORS ON
POUNDING BECAUSE- OKAY
EDUCATION OF EIGHTY FOUR NINETY
NINE FIRST AND FOREMOST THANK
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR ON
CARRYING THIS BILL CLIENTS AND
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US.
ON ON THIS IS THE IT'S A PIECE
BUDGET BECAUSE THE FIRST THAT I
A CARD BUT BACK IN TIME BECAUSE
IT. TWENTY WE WERE ABLE TO COME
TOGETHER WHEN THE INDUSTRY
REPRESENTATIVES SIDE OF THE
INDUSTRY AND THEIR FAMILIES TO
COME TOGETHER AND PRODUCE A
COMPREHENSIVE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. THAT IN FACT WILL
PROTECT CONSUMERS PARTICULARLY
AND IT COVERED WELL THAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO FIND. A PLACE
FOR THEIR LOVED ONES AND FAMILY
MEMBERS FRIENDS TO GO INTO JAIL
AND THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO TWITTER
TO SOMEBODY. THEY WERE CORAL
FOREST INDUSTRY IN- WHICH IS-
COMPRISED OF LARGE NATIONAL. AS
WELL FOLLOW UP LOCAL AGENCIES
LAST AND REGULATE ON AND WE
BELIEVE THAT A FOUR NINETY NINE
WILL PUT OF THOSE REGULATIONS.
THIS LEGISLATION IS A
COMPROMISE. LEGISLATION BOB IN
FACT- ON BOTH SIDES AND SHE'S
LIKE WE IT WE THINK IT'S A
REALLY GOOD MEASURE BASED ON
BACK ON THE WEBSITE COMBINATION
OF THE MULTI. ARE WORKING ON
THAT- AND BURDEN. SIX YEAR OF
WORKING ON THAT I WE BELIEVE
THAT A GOOD OF WHAT. AND-
ADDITIONALLY IF MENTIONED ON
LAST YEAR COLDER SOMEONE TO
CALL MIND HEN ABOUT. EIGHTY
TWO NINE TWENTY IT'S PAST MAN
LEE AND HOPE TO THE AN UPDATE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY. AND TO
GIVE THEM FOR ON THE.
TWENTY IF
THERE'S ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE TO ME PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. LEAVE WE HAVE LINED ONE
HUNDRED FIFTY ONE ONE MOMENT.
Q. ONE. ONE FIVE ONE INSURANCE
OF GUESTS WILL HAVE MEDICARE
MEMBERS ARE NOT HANDLED
REPRESENTING SIX BEDS DOT ORG
DISSOCIATION OF RESIDENTIAL
CARE FACILITIES FOR THE ELDERLY
AND DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED WE
COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
YOU KNOW TAKING ON THIS EFFORT
AGAIN WE'VE BEEN TRYING FOR AT
LEAST SIX YEARS TO I HAVE
LEGISLATION PASSED REGULATING
THE REFERRAL AGENCY INDUSTRY WE
DO THOUGH HAVE A SUPPORT IF
AMENDED POSITION- IN OUR
AMENDMENT IT THAT WE'RE TAKING
IS THAT OF AN AGENCY RECEIVED A
REQUEST TO SEIZE CONTACT. THAT
SHOULD HAPPEN IMMEDIATELY WE
DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD EXPECT%
WAIT FIFTEEN DAYS WE IMAGINE A
SCENARIO WHERE RESIDENT
ACTUALLY PASSES AWAY OR YEAH
THE ONLY PERSON PASSED AWAY AND
THE FAMILY IS CONTACTED BY
LOCAL AGENCIES DO THOSE FIFTEEN
DAYS AND IN WHAT IS VERY TRAGIC
LIKE THAT SO WE HAVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILL CONSIDER
THAT. REQUEST. OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. YES IT LOOKS LIKE
THERE ARE MORE WE'RE GOING ALL
IN ONE NINETY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NOTIFY I APOLOGIZE ANY MY
COMPUTER TO UPDATE HERE OKAY.
WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO EIGHTEEN
TWO ONE EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
PATRICK SHANNON I REPRESENT
CARING DOT COM A CO SPONSOR OF
THIS LEGISLATION. WE'VE BEEN
WORKING FOR SIX OR SEVEN YEARS
FOR THIS LEGISLATION I THINK WE
HAVE A GOOD PIECE THAT HAS-
ROUND SUPPORT SO I URGE YOUR
AYE VOTE PLEASE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'LL GO TO LINE TWO
SIXTEEN TO SIXTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO SIXTEEN DID YOU WANT
TO EXPRESS YOUR SUPPORT. MORE
MOVED A LOT NINE ONE SIXTY NINE
ONE SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO THIS IS LINDA ARE MEANT.
REPRESENTING NATIONAL PLACEMENT
REFERRAL ALLIANCE THE NATIONAL
TRADE ASSOCIATION FOR LOCAL
REFERRAL AGENCIES WE URGE
SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL AND WE
BELIEVE IT'S A VERY SPARE
COMMONSENSE BILL THAT IS
DEFINITELY NEEDED BUT WE DO
AGREE WITH THE COMMENTS FROM
THE SIX BADGE- ORGANIZATION
THAT IT SHOULD BE FAIR. THAT
WHEN ANY COMPANY HAS CONTACTED
AND ASKED TO SPEAK CONTACT THAT
THAT SHOULD STOP IMMEDIATELY
NOT FIFTEEN DAYS LATER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THERE ARE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR-
HARPER OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ONLINE.
IT ALLEGES SPEAKING OPPOSITION
ON THIS BUILD ME PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO THAT'S ONE AND
THEN. ZERO Q. THERE NO LINES IN
Q. THANK YOU OPERATOR I DO WE
HAVE ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION AND
RTS ROOM NOW OKAY OPERATORS ARE
ANY ONE ON THE LINE IN THE
PUBLIC THAT WANTS TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. IF THERE'S ANY
OPPOSITION YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE OF THEIR-
FOR ANY OPPOSITION. AND WE HAVE
NOT POSITIONING HERE AT THE
PRIME MINISTER THANK YOU
OPERATOR. THE SECOND THANK YOU
TO HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR ANY
OTHER. AS SOMEONE WHO'S LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
LOOK FORWARD TO MOVING THE BILL
FORWARD AND I DEFINITELY WILL
CONSIDER I'M TALKING TO- AND-
IMPLEMENTING AN AMENDMENT IF
THAT'S WHAT WE CALL HARPER AND
I LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THEM AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BIBLE. THANK YOU SIMONE
AND THANK YOU FOR CARRYING THIS
THIS BILL- WE HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY AGING LONG
TERM CARE COMMITTEE. CALDERON
HI CALDERON AYE DAVIES. DAVIES
HI ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA I'D CHOI
HI CHOI I GIPSON. STONE RIGHT
STONE HI BILL APPROVED BY THE
FOOD I II WARD. WORD I THIRTY
SEVEN ZERO THANK YOU
CONGRATULATIONS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OF THE I BELIEVE YOU
HAVE ANOTHER BILLION YES THANK
YOU MADAM. CHAIR AND MEMBERS- I
WILL NOT PRESENT MY FINAL BILL
TODAY D. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
RELATING TO THE SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION OF PRESCHOOL STUDENTS
THE BILL HAS THREE MAJOR
COMPONENTS EACH OF WHICH WILL
STRENGTHENED CALIFORNIA'S EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION SYSTEM TO
BETTER SERVE OUR STATE. FIRST
THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT THE
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION OF
PRESCHOOL AGE STUDENTS DROP
CALIFORNIA EARLY LEARNING
SYSTEM. NATIONAL DATA HAS
INDICATED TO VERY CONCERNING
TRENDS AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION NOT ONLY ARE THE
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS MORE
COMMON IN PRESCHOOL- IN THE
PRESCHOOL SETTING DOWN IN K.
TWELVE THEY ARE ALSO
DISPROPORTIONATELY IMPACT
CHILDREN OF COLOR. ACCORDING TO
A REPORT FROM THE US DEPARTMENT
OF EDUCATION OFFICE OF CIVIL
RIGHTS AFRICAN AMERICAN
CHILDREN REPRESENT 18% OF
PRESCHOOL ENROLLMENT BUT 42% OF
PRESCHOOL SUSPENSIONS. RESEARCH
HAS ALSO INDICATED THAT THE
SCHOOL EXPULSION AND SUSPENSION
PRACTICES ARE ASSOCIATED WITH
NEGATIVE EDUCATIONAL AND LIFE
OUTCOMES. IN ADDITION TO
HARMING YOUNG CHILD'S ACADEMIC
PROSPECTS RESEARCH HAS ALSO
FOUND THAT SUSPENSIONS AND
EXPULSIONS DO NOTHING TO IMPACT
THE ROOT CAUSE OF CHALLENGING
BEHAVIOR. WELL THIS FIRST MAJOR
COMPONENT IDENTIFIES A KEY
PROBLEM CALIFORNIA'S PRESCHOOL
SYSTEM AND MOVES TO IMMEDIATELY
AND HARM FOR PRACTICES THE NEXT
COMPONENT OF THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO CREATE A PROACTIVE
SOLUTION. AND WE ARE DOING THIS
THROUGH THE USE OF EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTATION OTHER
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS EASY M. H.
C. B. C. M. H. C. SERVICES ARE
A PROVEN MOEL WORRY MENTAL
HEALTH PROFESSIONAL WILL ENTRY
PRESCHOOL SETTING. AND PROVIDE
SUPPORT TO THE STUDENT THE
STAFF AND THE FAMILIES THESE
SERVICES CREATE A MEANS OF
PROVIDING ADEQUATE SUPPORT TO
TEACHERS CHILDREN AND FAMILIES
TO PROMOTE POSITIVE MENTAL
HEALTH. BUT FOR THE EFFECTS OF
TOXIC STRESS AND TRAUMA AND
BRING OUT THE MOST OPTIMAL
DEVELOPMENT AND. LEARNING EACH
AND EVERY CHILD. SO WITH THIS
BILL WE ARE NOT SIMPLY TO HAND
OFF PROVIDERS. I'M SORRY WE'RE
NOT SIMPLY TYING THE HANDS OF
PROVIDERS BY LIMITING
SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
WE'RE ALSO PROVIDING THEM WITH
A NEW TOOL TO HELP ADDRESS THE
CHALLENGES. IN BEHAVIOR IN A
MORE HOLISTIC AND POSITIVE
MANNER. THE FINAL COMPONENT OF
THIS BILL WILL BE FOR THE STATE
TO BEGIN COLLECTING DATA ON THE
USE OF SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSIONS SO THAT POLICY
MAKERS HERE. CAN HAVE A
COMPLETE UNDERSTANDING OF HOW
OUR SYSTEM IS WORKING. THIS
LEGISLATION HAS HAD INPUT FROM
POLICY EXPERTS THROUGHOUT OUR
NATION AND ENJOYS A LARGE
AMOUNT OF SUPPORT. THE BILL HAS
NO KNOWN OPPOSITION AND IS
INCLUDED IN THE GOVERNOR'S
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE MASTER
PLAN RELEASED EARLIER THIS
YEAR. I ALSO WANT TO STATE THAT
IT'S A BILL THAT'S NEAR AND
DEAR TO ME I- SPENT SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN YEARS AS A TEACHER
THREE OF THOSE AS A
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER AND- I CAN
TELL YOU. FIRSTHAND THAT YOU
CAN ALWAYS TELL WHICH KIDS COME
IN WITH TRAUMA AND WHICH DON'T
AND WE DIDN'T HAVE THE TOOLS TO
ADDRESS THE TRAUMA WE WERE
EXPECTED TO. TEACH EVERY CHILD
THE SAME WAY AND SO FOR ME THIS
IS REALLY IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WE'RE ADDRESSING THE ROOT OF
THE CAUSE. AND NOT JUST FOR THE
CHILDREN AND THE FAMILIES BUT
THEY'RE ASSISTING THE TEACHERS
WHICH I THINK IS A CRITICAL
COMPONENT. BECAUSE WE'RE ALL
NOT GOOD TEACHERS KNOW A LOT
BUT WE DON'T WE'RE NOT A MENTAL
HEALTH PROVIDERS AND SO THIS
GIVES US AN OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE THOSE. THAT ASSISTANCE
TO THOSE TEACHERS AND THEN NOW
I HAVE ON THE PHONE OUR
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS THANK
YOU. THE OKAY. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS KAI JACKSON WITH
BLACK MEN FOR EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AN ORGANIZATION OF BLACK
MEN WHO ARE PARENTS UNCLES
BROTHERS AND SONS FROM THE
ENTIRETY OF CALIFORNIA IN THE
WAKE OF GEORGE FLOYD BLACK MEN
FOR EDUCATIONAL EUITY CAME
TOGETHER WHILE MILLIONS OF
PEOPLE EXPRESS A DESIRE TO
BUILD MORE EQUITABLE EDUCATION
SYSTEM TO INCLUDE EARLY
LEARNING CARE SYSTEM WE HAVE
SEEN AT THE SCHOOL LEVEL THAT
THE SUSPENSIONS AND EXPULSIONS
HAVE BEEN FOUND TO BE A DIRECT
PATHWAY INTO THE JUVENILE AND
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM BUT THE
REALITY IS THAT IT HAD
BEGINNING IN CHILDREN AS EARLY
AS- ZERO AGES ZERO TO FIVE. WE
SEE ELEVATED LEVELS OF
EXCLUSIONARY DISCIPLINE IN
NATIVE AMERICAN AND LATINO
LATINO CHILDREN YET NO OTHER
STUDENT GROUP EXPERIENCES LEVEL
THE DISPROPORTIONATE DISCIPLINE
GREATER THAN BLACK MALE
CHILDREN WELL MORE DATA IS
NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA GROWING
BODY OF EVIDENCE IN A REPORT BY
DEAN THE PROFESSORS AT UCLA AND
SAN DIEGO STATE UNIVERSITY
FOUND THAT BLACK BOYS FOR FIVE
POINT SIX TIMES MORE LIKELY TO
BE SUSPENDED THAN THE STATE
AVERAGE FURTHERMORE A REPORT BY
WALTER GILLIAM IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN FOUND THAT MILLIE MANY
PRESCHOOL TEACHERS LOOK FOR
DISRUPTIVE BEHAVIOR OFTEN
HAVING AN ACUTE FOCUS ON
CHILDREN OF COLOR MORE THAN ANY
OTHER GROUP. I LIKE TO BE CLEAR
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT AND IS
NOT INTENDED DEVELOP BY
TEACHERS AND PROVIDERS OR AN
EXTREMELY VALUABLE AND
APPRECIATED- A GROUP OF
PROFESSIONALS IN OUR STATE
HOWEVER IT IS ESSENTIAL THAT
EARLY LEARNING AND CARE SYSTEMS
WORK TO ELIMINATE THE
SUSPENSION OF YOUNG. CHILDREN
AND YOUNG BATES. INDIAN
CHILDREN LEARN AND CARE
INVOLVED HAPPEN TOWARDS SCHOOL
AND BY. AND ALSO ROLLED
STUDENTS. WITH THEIR- AS AN
ALTERNATIVE TO SUSPENSION AND
EXPULSION AS ASSEMBLY REMEMBER
RUBIO MENTIONED PROVIDERS CAN
ADDRESS BEHAVIOR AND CONSIDER
INTERVENTION SUPPORTS. SUCH AS
THE INVOLVEMENT OF FAMILY
MEMBERS INDIVIDUALIZED
BEHAVIORAL INTERVENTION AND
OTHER IN SCHOOL STRATEGIES SUCH
AS EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH CONSULTATION. WHICH
REYES PROVIDERS AWARENESS ABOUT
THESE ISSUES AND BUILD THEIR
CAPACITY TO EXPOSING THEM TO
CONCRETE ALTERNATIVES. THIS
BILL IS ABOUT INCLUSION THE
GOAL IS ABOUT KEEPING OUR KIDS
AND LEARNING CARE ENVIRONMENTS.
NOT TO ISOLATE OR REMOVE THEM
FROM THOSE STATUS. THE BILL
ENSURE THAT OUTCOME BY
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL ASSISTANCE
AND RESOURCES AND TOOLS TO
PROVIDERS. JEFF IN CLOSING TO
REINFORCE WHAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RUBIO SAID. THIS BILL WOULD
ONLY BE USED AS A LAST RESORT
AND IT IN EXTRAORDINARY
CIRCUMSTANCES. WHERE SIRIUS
INVALIDATED EIGHTY CONCERNS ARE
ADDED PERTAINS TO EXPLOSION
AND- THIS PENSION. BILL
REQUIRED THE STATE TO COLLECT
AND PUBLISH DATA ON
EXCLUSIONARY PRACTICES AND
STRENGTHENS DUE PROCESS. FOR
FAMILIES THAT ARE IMPACTED BY
SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION. IT
PROVIDE EQUITABLE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL STUDENTS
AND ELIMINATE EXCLUSIONARY
PRACTICES. THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
THE PRESCHOOL TO PRISON
PIPELINE AND LASTLY IT'S
PRINTED BEEN CLARIFIED THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION SERVICES. PROVIDED
FOR CHILDREN AND STATE
PRESCHOOL AND GENERAL CHILD
CARE SETTINGS. I THANK YOU AND
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS ON. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK
MISTER JACK ON. COMPLETE OPEN
THE LINE FOR NAY WITNESS SINCE
THE TEAM SLOAN. FULL. YOUR LINE
SHOULD BE OPEN. HELLO I AM
TINA'S FLOWN WITH KIDDING GO
HEAD ANGLE IS THE LARGEST CHILD
CARE AND PRESCHOOL PROVIDER IN
THE BAY AREA AND OFFERS
THOUSANDS OF CHILDREN NURTURING
ENVIRONMENT TO LEARN AND
DEVELOP WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR AB THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
SHE THE END POINT OF TEACHERS
AND CHILDCARE. PROVIDERS ON
YOUNG CHILDREN IT'S PROFOUND
TEACHERS DESERVE AND REQUIRE
ADEQUATE SUPPORT TO BE
EFFECTIVE ESPECIALLY. IN THE
FACE OF PROFOUND CHALLENGES.
UPDATED WERE LATER TO CHILDREN
BEHAVIORS QUITE EASY A PROGRAM.
OUT CALIFORNIA YEAR AFTER YEAR
AND INTERVENTIONS TO DATE HAVE
NOT BEEN SUCCESSFUL. AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE PROVIDES
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION I THINK HE'S
SUPPORT TO ADDRESS THE PROBLEMS
THAT ARISE AND CULMINATE INTO
THE ULTIMATE CONSEQUENCE FOR
CHILDREN THEIR REMOVAL OF
ACCESS. EARLY LEARNING SETTINGS.
THE SUSPENSION AND EXPULSION.
SHE SHE INGREDIENTS OF THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL HEALTH.
INCLUDE IT'S EVIDENCE BASED
MENTAL HEALTH PERSPECTIVE THE
COLLABORATIVE PARTNERSHIP IN
ECSTATIC WHICH IS BETWEEN
CONSULTANT EDUCATOR AND FAMILY.
WHAT THE TIME IT CREATES AND
THE PROSPECT THAT FACILITATE
THE UNDERSTAND AND GAIN INSIGHT
INTO THE COMPLEX ISSUES. FROM
THESE INSIGHTS SHALER
STRATEGIES ARE GENERATED AND
IMPLEMENT IT. I AM A LICENSED
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL AND
I A THIRD OF THE CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH PEOPLE CAN'T. WE
DELIVER THIS TRANSFORMATIVE
CONSULTATION AT KATANGA AND IT
WORK. AB THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
OUTLINES THE WORK FORCE AND
THEIR SPECIALIZED SKILLS
KNOWLEDGE AND EXPERIENCE
REQUIRED TO BUILD THE ECP
SYSTEM CAPACITY AND MORE FULLY
ACHIEVED THE IMPACT IT
PROMISES. TO HELP ALL CHILDREN
EQUITABLY TOWARD THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL WITH THIS CREW WHEN
APPROACH OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
MENTAL HEALTH COMPLICATION
BETTER AND MORE EQUITABLE
OUTCOMES ARE POSSIBLE. FUTURE
ARE THEY DIFFERENT I
RESPECTFULLY URGE YOU TO
SUPPORT AB. THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISS LONG.
DO WE HAVE ANY ANY TO SUPPORT
IN THE RTS ROOM. OKAY TO HAVE
IT OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO. ONE AND THEN
ZERO IF YOU ARE INTO PORT. AND
MADAM CHAIR WE HAVE NO SUPPORT
QUEUE AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU I
DO WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OPERATOR. AND IF
YOU'RE NOT THE VISION YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO NOW.
ONE AND THEN ZERO FEAR IN
OPPOSITION. AND NO OPPOSITION
IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME AN OBJECT
OKAY THANK YOU DOES THAT
INCLUDE PUBLIC OPPOSITION.
OPERATOR. YES OKAY THERE IS NO
NO I THINK YOU. THANK YOU- TOO
MANY MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR OKAY AND SOME OF THEM
NUMBER THIRTY COULD HAVE YOUR-
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I JUST
WANTED TO. THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS UP THANK THE
AUTHOR AND TEACHER. AND IF WE
COULD BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR MUCH. MORE. MORE
THANK YOU ALSO WANT TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR- OFFERING THIS
FOR PUTTING THE WORK INTO THIS
I'M CLEARLY A REALLY CRITICAL
AREA UPDATE THAT IS NEEDED- AS
THE PARENT OF- NOW MY SECOND
CHILD GOING THROUGH CHILD
DEVELOPMENT. I CAN'T IMAGINE-
YOU KNOW. A RANDOM SITUATION.
WHERE THEY WOULD TRY TO USE A
SUSPENSION OR EXPULSION ON ANY
OF THE KIDS ARE THAT HE IS
GOING TO- THE CENTER WITH- THEY
ALL LOVE TO CHILDREN- THEY ALL
COME WITH DIFFERENT SETS OF
CHALLENGES THAT IT DOES NOT
MEAN WE ABANDON THEM. WE FIGURE
IT OUT WE PROVIDE AND THE TOOLS
THAT I THINK SHOULD BE A
BASELINE THE POLICY HERE FOR
THE STATE AND I THINK THAT'S
WHERE THIS BILL IS HEADED IN IS
SO IMPORTANT- AND TO BE ABLE TO
USE THIS AN OPPORTUNITY ALSO TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT DISPARITIES
THAT WE KNOW ARE OCCURRING YES-
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT SO- I ALSO
WOULD BE HONORED TO SERVE AS A
CO AUTHOR AS WELL AND I REALLY.
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THIS WORK.
THANK AYE SOMEONE TRIED TWO
REQUIRE. THANK YOU CHAIR. ON A
SAN MULLIN- RUBIO. I SHE THE-
SMALL MANY BENEFITS SOME OF-
YOUR BILL. ON TO PROHIBIT. THE
CHILDREN ARE YOUNG CHILDREN
FROM PRESCHOOL OR SO TO BE
SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED FOR THE
OF BEHAVIORS- AND- IT. THERE
ARE SOME EXCEPTIONS SO
PROHIBITING UNLESS IF YOU CAN
EXPLAIN EXPAND ON WHAT THE LAST
PORTION. IN WHAT CIRCUMSTANCES
SO THAT THE SUSPENSION OR-
EXPLOSION WOULD BE ALLOWED TO
AND- MAYBE EVEN BEFORE THAT
TIME. ALWAYS- FOR THIS KIND OF
EXTREME MEASURES SET TO BE
CONSIDERED OR TAKEN- PROBABLY-
TRADITIONALLY TEACHERS OR OR
THE ENTITY COULD NOT HANDLE THE
CHILD. SO THIS ONE IS A
PROHIBITING UNLESS A FEW.
EXCEPTIONS TO WHICH OUR WHEN I
HEAR ABOUT. WELL AND OBVIOUSLY.
THE DECIDE TO FOR EXAMPLE WERE
ARRESTED BEHAVIOR- IF THE CHILD
CARE TIPS ON- MANY DIFFERENT
FORMS OF AGGRESSIVE BEHAVIOR
LIKE CRICKETING CONSISTENTLY.
AND THAT THERE'S A DEAL TO SIDE
OF ALL EQUATION VICTIMS MMHM
OKAY MAYBE WE CAN CALL IT. EVEN
THOUGHT THIS CHILDREN BORN MAY
NEED THAT ON ON WHAT THEY ARE
DOING. UNTIL THEY BECOME OLDER
SO AT THIS A LITTLE CHILDREN
THIS IS JUST A DIFFERENT
PERSONALITY CHARACTER
EXHIBITING THAT KIND OF THINGS.
AND- ON AT UPON DO THAT DON'T
AS THE GOOD COUPON. BUT IF
YOU'RE A QUESTION A PARTICULAR
CHARGES SO CONTINUES TO BE
HARASSED OR BULLIED. ARE THERE
SOME VICTOR. AND THE CHILD IS A
PROHIBITED FROM BEING EXPELLED
INTO CONTINUOUSLY COMES INTO
YOUR CHILD HAPPENS TO BE THE
VICTIM AND CONTINUES TO HARASS
YOUR CHILD IS A MENTAL. SPATTER
SO WILL BE DAMAGED. AND JUST
START START THE PSYCHOLOGICAL
DAMAGE OR BE YOU KNOW HONG. CAN
YOU EXPLAIN THAT ASPECT YOU AT
THE SIDE OF THE EQUATION
ABSOLUTELY- WELL FIRST AND
FOREMOST THE CHILDREN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT ARE THREE AND
FOUR YEAR OLDS AND- THROUGH THE
STATISTICS THAT WE WERE
REVEALING ONE OF THEM THE MAJOR
CAUSES OF THE EXPLOSION HAS
BEEN BITING- IF YOU LOOK AT A
DEVELOPMENTAL CHARRED- THREE
AND FOUR YEAR OLDS BITE BECAUSE
THEY CAN'T EXPRESS THEMSELVES
AND COMMUNICATE. SO THAT'S THE
ONLY WAY THAT THEY CAN
EXPRESSED FRUSTRATION OR ANY
YOU KNOW ANY OTHER ANYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON AT HOME SO
THAT'S A PRIMARY YOU KNOW
WANTED TO POINT THAT OUT TO
THIRTY THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLDS- BUT TO YOUR POINT AS A
TEACHER IS A FORMER
KINDERGARTEN TEACHER I CAN TELL
YOU THAT I CAN HAVE THE BEST
PLANS AND THAT- AND ONE DAY AND
ONE CHILD CAN DISRUPT THE WHOLE
ENTIRE DAY. SO WHEN WE WERE
WORKING ON THIS BILL I TOOK
THAT INTO CONSIDERATION THE
PROBLEM IS THAT THAT WE CAN
EXPEL CHILDREN AND THEY'RE
REALLY NOT GETTING ANY KIND OF
SERVICES WERE JUST REMOVING
THEM FROM THE SITUATION AND ARE
NOT ONLY ARE WE REMOVING THEM
FROM THE SITUATION THEIR GAIN
CONDITION THAT IF THEY ACT THIS
WAY THEY GET TO GO HOME. RIGHT
SO NOW WE'RE ENCOURAGING BY BY
SENDING THEM HOME WE'RE REALLY
PROMOTING THE FACT THAT HEY IF
YOU DO THIS YOU'RE GOING TO GET
TO GO HOME AND SO THAT'S ALSO
DETRIMENTAL TO THE EDUCATION OF
THAT CHILD AND TO YOUR POINT
ABOUT THE OTHER KIDS IN THE
CLASSROOM YOU ARE CORRECT. THE
POINT TO THIS BILL IS THAT IT'S
NOT JUST PREVENTING THE
EXPULSION ARE THE SUSPENSION
BUT IT'S ALSO PROVIDING THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES FOR ED
TRADITIONALLY WE'VE ONLY DONE
IT TO THE CHILD INTO THE FAMILY
AS IF TEACHERS MAGICALLY KNOW
HOW TO DEAL WITH THIS AND THEY
DON'T. SO THAT MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION TAKES THE THREE
COMPONENTS THAT CHILD THE
FAMILY AND THE TEACHER BECAUSE
A LOT OF TEACHERS LIKE I SAID
I'M AN EXPERT AT A LOT OF
THINGS OR I CAN TEACH A LOT OF
CONTENT BUT I DON'T I'M NOT
QUALIFIED TO PROVIDE ANY MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES TO CHILDREN
BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THE CHILD CAN
BE ACTING UP- AND YOU THINK
THEY'RE JUST BEING BULLIES. BUT
THEY MIGHT NOT HAVE EATEN IN
THE MORNING. MOM AND DAD GOT
INTO A FIGHT IN THE EVENING YOU
KNOW WE ARE HOLD. OF THIS THAT
THE IN AND THE CHILDREN DON'T
KNOW HOW TO EXPRESS IT
ESPECIALLY THREE AND FOUR YEAR
OLD. SO THE MENTAL HEALTH
COMPONENT NOT ONLY HELPS THE
CHILD AMBER THE FAMILY. BUT
ALSO THE TEACHER. TO DEFLECT
THE SITUATION DIFFUSE IT AT A
DIFFERENT WAY. BUT IT'S NOT
JUST. A CHART OF THIS IS WHAT
YOU DO THIS IS. SPECIFICALLY
DESIGNED TO SIT WITH THE FAMILY
WITH A CHILD- THE PARENT AND
THE TEACHER TO IDENTIFIED THAT
CHILD'S PARTICULAR- WHY THERE.
ARE BEING AGGRESSIVE OR
WHATEVER THAT THE ISSUE MAYBE.
SO THIS IS NOT. A CHECK OFF
LIST- THIS IS INDIVIDUALIZED
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES. THAT
INCLUDES THE TEACHERS SO THAT
THE TEACHER CAN DIFFUSE THE
SITUATION. NOW IF IT CONTINUES
AND WE'RE GETTING TO THE POINT
WHERE. YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
THEN. THERE THERE SHOULD THERE
SHOULD BE A MEETING- BETWEEN
THE MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL
AND THE FAMILY TO TRY TO
IDENTIFY. IT ARE THERE OTHER
THINGS THAT CAN BE DONE. AND IF
NOT. IS THE MENTAL HEALTH
CONSULTATION EVEN HOT OUT
HELPING AND IF IT'S NOT HELPING
AT THAT POINT YOU HAVE A
MEETING WITH. THE FAMILY. AND
BUT THE PERSONALITIES CALL AND
DECIDE WHAT THE NEXT STEP WOULD
BE. BUT I THINK AND I BELIEVE
LIKE I SAID AS A AS A FORMER
TEACHER IS THAT WE'RE NOT
GETTING TO THE ROOT. OF THE
ISSUE IF WE JUST SEND THEM HOME
YOU'RE JUST SENDING THEM HOME
FOR WHAT. YOU CAN EXPECT. THE
KIDS TO THE CHILD TO COME BACK
THE NEXT DAY AND BE FIXED.
BECAUSE WE HADN'T HAVEN'T
PROVIDED ANY KIND OF SUPPORT
YOU JUST SENT THEM HOME AND
GUESS WHAT THEY DID ALL DAY.
PLAY VIDEO GAMES WATCH TV
WHATEVER THE ISSUE MAYBE. BUT
NEVER ADDRESS THE ACTUAL ISSUE.
SO HOPEFULLY THAT ANSWERS YOUR
QUESTION THAT. WE CAN TAKE
STEPS. TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PROVIDE. MENTAL HEALTH
SERVICES- FOR THE TEACHER THAT
BOTH. THE STUDENT AND THE
FAMILY TO TRY AND SUPPORT HEM
THE BEST WAY POSSIBLE. IF IT'S
AN EXTREME CASE OF COURSE
THAT'S GOING TO BE ADDRESSED
LATER- AND IN TERMS OF THE
CHILDREN THAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT BEING VICTIMIZED. IF WE
DON'T ADDRESS THE ISSUES. RIGHT
NOW. THAT CHILD. IS GOING TO
CONTINUE IN KINDERGARTEN FIRST
GRADE SO GET INVENTOR GRADE-
ACT. OUT THIS. SO YOUR CHILD-
THAT YOU WERE THINKING MIGHT BE
A VICTIM RIGHT NOW MAY BE A
VICTIM FOR CAN TO FIRST AND
SECOND AND THIRD GRADE BECAUSE
WE'RE NOT FIXING THAT. OR AT
LEAST ASSISTING THE CHILD AND
WHATEVER ISSUES THAT THEY'RE
HAVING. AND SO. AS A TEACHER I
CAN TELL YOU THAT IT AGAIN I
CAN HAVE THE BEST LESSON PLANS.
AND ONE CHILD CAN DISRUPT THE
WHOLE ENTIRE DAY BUT UNLESS WE
ACTUALLY TREAT WHATEVER THE
ISSUE IS. AND INSTEAD OF JUST
IGNORING IT AND THEY JUST GO
HOME. AND THEY COME BACK THE
NEXT DAY YOU HAVEN'T FIXED
ANYTHING SO. BUT MY HOPE IS AND
I THINK- THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
GOING WITH THIS IS PROVIDING
MENTAL HEALTH- CONSULTATION.
WILL HELP THE PARENT THE
STUDENT AND THE TEACHER TO TRY
AND- IDENTIFY WHAT THE ISSUES
ARE. AND IF THERE ARE EXTREME
CASES OBVIOUSLY YOU HAVE TO SIT
DOWN WITH THE SCHOOL PERSONNEL
AND FIGURE OUT A DIFFERENT. A
DIFFERENT- A WAY OF ADDRESSING
THOSE ISSUES BUT SENDING THEM
HOME DOESN'T DO ANYTHING FOR
ANYBODY. I HOPE I ANSWERED YOUR
QUESTION. ON THAT BRING SAMPLE.
NEXT TO LEVEL OR- A QUESTION-
IF OUR OP. OF A PRESCHOOL OR-
AND- YOU APPEAR REQUIRES
INVOLVING PARENTS AND THEM
MENTAL HEALTH EXPERTS. BEFORE
EXPENSE- IT IS SUSPENDING
EXPANDING THE SHONDA SO THAT
IS- WHO'S GOING TO PROVIDE THAT
THE MEANT MENTAL HEALTH A
PROVIDER- THE OPERATOR OR THE
COUNTY OR STATE TO WHO'S GONNA
PAY FOR THE- MENTAL HAVE OKAY
SO FIRST OF ALL SO THIS BILL IS
SPECIFICALLY TO ANY- PRESCHOOL
OR ARE EASY CENTER THAT IS I
HAD FUNDING FROM THE STATE. AND
THEN WE WILL PROVIDE THE
FUNDING FOR THE MENTAL HEALTH
CALLED CONSULTATION WE DID AYE
AYE A PORTION OF THIS BILL-
LAST YEAR TWO YEARS AGO MY
DOCTOR TWO YEARS AGO AND IT'S
BEEN WORKING SO FAR WE DID HAVE
SOME SOME ISSUES WITH THE
FUNDING BECAUSE IT WAS PROP- IT
WAS ALL BUDGETED THROUGH THE
STATE. YOU MEAN THE STATE YES
THE STATE SO ANYBODY THAT
RECEIVED ANY STATE FUNDING IS
THE ONE THAT HAS TO COMPLY WITH
THE MENTAL HEALTH CONSULTATIONS
AND WOULD BACK THEM THE MONEY
COMES FROM IS NOT GOING TO COST
TO THE OPERATOR YEAH. I SEE
OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
COMING. I HAVE A CELL. WHICH IS
TO CLOSE THANK YOU EVERY STEP
ASK FOR YOUR IPHONE. THANK YOU
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION. A
SECOND- SEVEN SIX THREE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE CALDERON HI CALDERON
AYE DAVIES. DAVIES I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I CHOI AYE CHU AYE AYE
GIPSON. STONE STONE I THE
LIKUD. LIKUD I MORD. WORK I.
BUT SEVENTY ZERO GRADUALLY
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME. OKAY
SO WE HAVE ONE MORE BILLABLE
COMMITTEE TODAY BY FAMILY
MEMBERS SANTIAGO- I BELIEVE HE
IS ACTUALLY IN ANOTHER
COMMITTEE RIGHT NOW- DO WE HAVE
AN ETA ON. HIS ARRIVAL. TEN
FIVE TWO MINUTES OKAY- WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE OF THINGS- I WAS
BROUGHT TO MY ATTENTION THAT
THERE WERE A FEW CALLERS ON THE
LINE THAT DID NOT HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO REGISTER THEIR
PUBLIC SUPPORT FOR OPPOSITION
SO OPERATOR COULD WE PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE AND PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO ANYONE THAT
WANTS TO DO SO ON ANY OF THE
BILLS. WE DISCUSSED TODAY.
THANK YOU AND ANY OF THE BILLS
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
AND WE WILL GO TO LINE OF ONE
FORTY FOUR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS SHELBY DO VERY
I'M WITH A CALIFORNIA ACCESS
COALITION AS WELL AS THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL OF COMMUNITY
AND BEHAVIORAL HEALTH AGENCIES.
AND WE ARE JUST DURING OUR
SUPPORT FOR ONE THREE SIX ONE
THANK YOU. GREAT THANK YOU. AN
EXTRA LINE OF ONE SIXTY THREE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE SIXTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN. HI YOU
GOT ME YES UP MY APOLOGIES TO
MY COLLEAGUES AND- ORG SO I'M
FINE WITH THAT CALIFORNIA
COUNCIL KEATING HOW CAN YOU
PICK THE RIGHT PART. GREAT
THANK YOU MEXICO LINE OF ONCE
FIVE AIRLINERS OKAY. HI
AFTERNOON THIS IS UNDER PERRY
REPRESENTING THE HEALTH TURBO
AS A WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT OR- I'M OPPOSITION
THANK YOU AT THE TIME OKAY
THANK YOU- ADAM SECRETARY- ME
LET THE CALL. FILE ITEM TEN AB
FIVE FOUR NINE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I VOTED. EIGHT TO
ZERO. FILE ITEM ELEVEN AB EIGHT
TO NINE CURRENT FED SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA RANDALL II CURRENT
VOTE SEVENTY ZERO. FILE ITEM
TWELVE EIGHTY NINE THIRTY TWO
THE CURRENT VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ALRIGHT
CURRENT VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO.
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY EIGHT CURRENT VOTER
SIXTY TWO.
OKAY.
I'M SECRETARY
AS SOME MEMBERS GIPSON IS BACK
WITH THAT. WITH THE CALL.
FILE
ITEM. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY NINE
FOUR NINE NINE CURRENT VOTE IS
SEVEN TO ZERO GIPSON HI GIPSON
AYE THE VOTE IS EIGHT ZERO.
FILE ITEM TWENTY THREE AB
THIRTEEN SIXTY ONE THE CURRENT
VOTED SEVEN TO ZERO GIPSON
GIPSON AYE VOTE IS. EIGHT ZERO.
K. THANK YOU. SO I BELIEVE
WE'RE WAITING FOR MR SANTIAGO
TO HIS LAST PRESENTER AND HE'S
SUPPOSED TO BE HERE PROBABLY
WITHIN FIVE MINUTES NOW
HOPEFULLY. OKAY SO I APOLOGIZE
IT. I CAN GO GET IT. FIVE
HOLIDAYS FOR THE DELAY. WE
COULD JUST WAIT FOR FIVE
MINUTES AND IF HE- WHERE YOU. I
THINK YOU ALL HAVE PLACES TO BE.
IT'S NOT YOUR FAULT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE. HER
JOB IS HERE RIGHT NOW. OKAY.
EVERYTHING.
IT IS- COMMITTEE
OTHER OKAY YEAH OKAY. POSIBLES
COMMITTEE. HE HAS ONE OF ALL OF
THE OTHER-
THIS IS THE. ONE
YEAH THE STORM. WHAT ABOUT
SIXTY. YEAH.
YEAH.
OKAY. YEAH.
YEAH RIGHT. YEAH. YEAH. WELCOME
MR SANTIAGO. I COME ON AT.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT. YEAH
I BELIEVE IT WOULD BE A
PRODUCTION BECAUSE LIKE THE ONE
PERSON ON THE PHONE. NAMSAN OR
MAKE A QUICK. HI THANK YOU
MA'AM SEVERAL 100% I'LL BE
BRIEF IF IT'S OKAY WITH ME AND
I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE AB
TWENTY TWO WERE TO PROVIDE SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS WORTH OF
MERCHANTS HE TOOK THE FOOD TO
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK MY VOTE. THANK YOU MR
SANTIAGO- OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
FIRST WITNESS IN SUPPORT MARK
LAURIE. I'LL CERTAINLY THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON I'M
BARKLOW REPRESENT YOUR COUNTY
FOOD BANK AND WE SUPPORT AB TWO
TWENTY ONE AND IT'S ONE TIME
PROVISION OF EMERGENCY GROCERY
CARDS FOR MOST VULNERABLE
FAMILIES. I AND I KNOW TIME IS
SHORT SO I WILL JUST ADD THAT
FROM A FOOD SUPPLY PERSPECTIVE
THE SUPPLY OF FOOD BANKS A
STRAIN. THAT AT OUR ORANGE
COUNTY FOOD BANK WE EXPERIENCED
A 50% DECREASE IN FOOD
DONATIONS DURING THE FIRST TWO
MONTHS OF THIS YEAR COMPARED TO
THE BOOK THE FOOD DONATIONS
RECEIVED DURING THE LAST TWO
MONTHS OF LAST YEAR. SO AB TWO
TWENTY ONE STRENGTHENS OUR
SAFETY NET AND THROWS A
LIFELINE TO OUR FAMILIES IN
MOST NEED AND IN MANY CASES
THESE ARE THE SAME SAME
FAMILIES WHO WERE MOST.
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY THE
CORPORATE CRISIS THANK YOU AND
WE ENCOURAGE SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SIR OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE QUEUE FOR THE NEXT
WITNESS IN SUPPORT. HI NATALIE
CABLE BECAUSE PPL IN CENTRAL
CALIFORNIA COULD BANKS ARE
GOING TO CONTROL PANEL ABSENT
ALI SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWO TWENTY ONE. OF NINETEEN HAS
EXACERBATED PRUDENT SECURITY
AND LAID BARE THE SYSTEMIC
INEQUALITIES THAT CONTRIBUTE TO
CHRONIC HUNGER AND FOOD
INSECURITY. PANDEMIC BEGAN
WE'VE SEEN AN AVERAGE 40%
INCREASE IN INDIVIDUALS AND
FAMILIES ACCESSING EMERGENCY
COULD NOT WORK AND IN OUR
REGION OUR FARMWORKERS AND
OTHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS AND-
THAT ARE UNDOCUMENTED HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED FROM FEDERAL AID AND
ASSISTANCE ARE THOSE THAT ARE
PIECING ASTRONOMICAL RATES OF
HUNGER NOW CURRENTLY MORE THAN
ONE ENTRY LIKE. MAX IT'S THE
CHILDREN. AB TWO TWENTY ONE OF
THEM NEEDED AND STRAIGHT
TOWARDS. AND THROUGH BANK NOT
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS
TO PROVIDE LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS. GROCERY CARDS
THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT
AND WE DEVELOP STRONG
PARTNERSHIPS. HOPING TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE POPULATION AND
USE OUR EXISTING PROGRAMS
TEMPERAMENTAL LEGISLATION NOT
ONLY WILL IT FIGHT HUNGER BUT
IT'LL BRING MUCH NEEDED
RESOURCES INTO THE COMMUNITY.
INCLUDING AFTER THE LEGISLATURE
RECOGNIZES THE IMPACT OF
COVERED NINETEEN- ARE
SIGNIFICANT LONG LASTING
EVERYTHING ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO FOR CHAMPIONING ADELE
AND ARSON COMMITTEE TO SUPPORT
THE BILL. EMPIRE TAKING AT
LEAST ONCE AND. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ADD TO HAVE ANY OTHER%
SO IN OUR- ROOM. OKAY THE
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE AN
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE. THANK YOU IF YOU ARE IN
SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE OF TWO THIRTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. WHO GOOD
AFTERNOON NONSTANDARD- I
BECAUSE I'M NOT SURE I WAS ON
HOLD FOR CLOSE HAD BEEN-
ACCEPTED EARLIER. DURING A
COLLECTION OKAY I I'M I'M- GO
AHEAD. I WILL- EARLIER CALLING
AT THE PORT AND- THE PHONE
LINES ARE OPEN OKAY WE ARE
ASKED TO CALL BACK AND- OKAY-
GO HEAD AND STATE THE BILL IN
YOUR POSITION- ANDERSON THE ARC
IN UCP CALIFORNIA COLLABORATION
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ONE SHOCKER AND DVELOPMENT
SERVICES. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU AN EXTRA LINE OF TWO TWENTY
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
CHRISTOPHER SPONSORS POLICY
ADVOCATE THE WASHINGTON ALONG
POVERTY WE'RE PROUD TO BE A CO
SPONSOR AN AWFUL REST
REGISTERING THE OUR SUPPORT OF
OUR CORE CARREGAR SURE THE
COLLISION FROM IMMIGRANT RIGHTS
WERE ALSO CO SPONSORS BILL.
THANK YOU AND I TOOK A LINE OF
ONE SEVENTY FIVE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. HI GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
ANDREA CARE REPRESENTING NO KID
HUNGRY WE AREN'T STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWENTY TWO HE WON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. MEXICO LINE OF
TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. TWO TWENTY ONE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. ANYONE CALIFORNIANS
SUPPORT. RIGHT THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE UP TO THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. TWO THIRTY FOR YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. MEXICO LINE OF
TWO THIRTY TWO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. I THINK IT UP HI THIS IS
BEN EVEN SHALL POLICIES. WILL
BE- CALIFORNIA MEDICAL CENTER
EXPRESSING OUR SUPPORT FOR
EIGHT MONTHS IN TWO MONTHS.
THANK YOU AND NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE UP TO THIRTY YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. BY TWO THIRTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. OKAY THANK YOU WILL GO TO
LINE OF THE TWO THIRTY SIX YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CALL ON
HOLY ON BEHALF. OF LONG BEACH
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MEXICO
LINE UP TO NINETEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. HELLO THIS IS NOT THE
ONLY RESPONSE CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES YES GO AHEAD. OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU WITH CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF FOOD BANKS
COSPONSOR FOR EIGHTY TWO TWENTY
ONE WE SUPPORTER WITNESSES
STATEMENTS INSTRUCTED ALL
CALIFORNIA THE BANKS ARE UNDER
SIMILAR STRAIN I'M AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I.
ABOUT. THANK YOU ANNEX WILL
LINE UP TO THIRTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. KELLY BURKE ON BEHALF
OF THE COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU THANKS OF A LINE OF TWO
THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
HI MARIA THEY TRANSPORTED THE
CALIFORNIA CATHOLIC CONFERENCE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT TO
THE LINE OF TWO THIRTY SEVEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO THIRTY
SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE
PROBLEM BECAUSE YOU HAVE A TIME
YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
WE'LL GO TO LINE OF TWO THIRTY
FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN. TWO
THREE FOR YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THE THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT YOUR CALL WITH
THE POOREST CALIFORNIA IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR WE HAVE NO MORE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO WE HAVE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ON
THE LINE. WE DON'T HAVE BEEN
MISTER WILLIAM. I DO NOT
BELIEVE SO THANK YOU OPERATOR
YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION I'M ON
THE PHONE LINES YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND ZERO FOR OPPOSITION.
AND THERE IS NO OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINES THANK YOU
OPERATOR. THANK YOU OPERATOR-
DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION RTS
ROOM. NO OKAY- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE. NO OKAY AT THE
MOMENT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL AND
THANK YOU FOR A- YOUR PATIENCE
THANK YOU HAVE A MOTIONS. OKAY
WE HAVE A MOTION AND SECOND
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THE MOTION IS THE PAST TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON I CALDERON
HI DAVIES. DAVIES HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HIGH CHOI. GIPSON
GIPSON ICE DOWN STONE I. HI
MORE LORD HI. BOTH SEVENTY ZERO
THANK YOU- THIS IS FOR THIS
HUMAN SERVICES COMMITTEES
COMPLETELY HEARING IS ADJOURNED.